Due to
a Joseph Rogan.
I'm good man.
How you doing?
Great to see you.
As always.
My Pool game was up to snuff.
Mine wasn't either.
We both sucked.
We smoked.
I smoked a cigar before the,
uh,
this podcast during the last one and I'm
all jittery now.
Yeah,
definitely.
Like everything's firing the nicotine
Jew in hamlet.
No,
but just your mouth and smoking and suck
on it.
You get a get a nicotine.
I feel like I'm left out of a certain
club.
Those guys who think it's really cool to
relax with cigar smoking,
it makes me nauseous.
Yeah,
it's a.
It doesn't make me relax.
It's fun.
I like to do it,
but it's a high ever.
They're lying to themselves.
That's a high.
It's a nicotine high,
late course letterman.
And those guys were into the Hay.
They get in there doing drugs.
Drugs.
That's crazy.
That's illegal,
isn't it?
God Damn drug den.
You know what's hilarious?
Hepped up on something Chile tell you.
But it's one of those things.
It's like so common and it's so part of
the culture that we look at that as
being less ridiculous and more like
reserved and intelligent than if someone
got together and in a little shack there
like a smoke shop and there was smoking
pot together.
Yeah.
Those people I guess.
Well I get older.
I get more of a buzz from coffee than I
do from Xanax.
You do?
Oh fuck you.
Because annex just makes me feel like
what I think a normal person feels like,
you know,
without the terrifying anxiety.
We talked about this before,
but like when did you,
when did you start getting anxiety?
A second grade.
Really?
Wow.
Yeah.
Second Grade,
but I'm really doing better.
Right.
Dr Says in 10 years I should be ahead of
it.
You never had anxiety of.
Definitely anxiety.
Yeah,
but about a specific thing.
The worst thing is just anxiety that you
don't even know what it's from.
Oh yeah.
I'm in the core of your being,
so it's an.
It's some sort of firing error or
something in your brain.
Yeah,
it's definitely a chemical thing.
And does anything else help it?
Like exercise help it or like alcohol,
alcohol helps.
But the thing about alcohol is the
rebound is worse than the high wire if
you have it.
If you have three hours of a buzz for
alcohol,
you'll have a 12 hour hangover.
Yeah.
Especially as you get older.
The hangovers get rougher and rougher
for me pretty much every year.
Well,
I never drank when I was young,
so this is all new to me the last few
years.
Like how many years?
A eight.
And I know you,
uh,
you stopped for awhile.
We talked about.
He stopped for a while.
So good.
I couldn't believe how good it feels.
Not that big of a hangover.
Yeah.
Holy Shit,
this is it.
But you like it?
Well,
I like the whole unit,
how they,
you know,
but the unbeknownst to the score and the
puffin laughing and throw it raise and
up,
like he made a big point.
I like that with alcohol,
that whole social thing.
I like to have a drink with you too
because it's like we're announcing
festivities,
like
what the time fun festivities has.
She is my friend and we,
uh,
you know,
we both sort of agreed that we're off on
a alcohol filled,
fun,
Romp Chitchat and laughter.
But no Duis,
no Duis.
That's uh,
that's,
that's where Uber came in and changed
the game.
So I can't take it with the fucking uber
anymore.
Can't everybody's trying to convince me
like there's something wrong with me.
You kind of take Uber.
I go,
I don't want to take over.
I don't want to get in the car with a
strange guy.
I don't want to get into his own car.
I wanna I want to either get a car
service or take a cab.
He's just an old school guy.
I just don't want to.
I mean it's like.
And the thing that's funny about Uber to
me is the idea like,
you know,
I used to drink maybe one,
two drinks tonight,
but now say say I drink all day because
the uber brings you got colic.
Now what's funny about Uber is they,
it's like the application connecting,
like connecting people to people that
want something and those people get all
the money I think.
And then they pay the drivers,
right?
It's not how it works because you it up.
Understand that when I moved to New
York,
they had medallions.
They have to spend thousands of dollars
to get them a day and to be able to
drive a commercial vehicle here.
Anybody can drive an uber.
How's that?
That's why it's really crazy.
Because they are independent contractors
like in New York,
used to be illegal.
Used to have these things called Gypsy
cabs.
They still do.
Do you remember that?
One year?
Um,
there was a,
I want to say more than 40 gypsy cab
drivers were murdered.
Really?
Yeah.
But find this out.
Gypsy cab driver murders in New York.
I think they would take them to like bad
neighborhoods and shoot them and rob
them.
So these cab drivers who are fucked,
you know,
they weren't making much money.
They had to take every fair they could
and they would take these guys or one
guy.
I mean,
who knows how many people actually wound
up being the people killing them.
It was just say 1990.
This story is from.
That sounds about right.
That's when I was living there.
Gypsy cab driver was found shot dead in
the bronx.
That's the only one.
There was a k killings are related to
the three,
the six one back then I want to say it
was some insane number,
man.
I really think it was more than 20.
I want to say it's 40.
For some reason.
Cavities didn't get a fair shake.
The oldest hookers got killed.
Got a lot of press.
Well they got press in New York,
but this is press in 1990 or 91 or
whatever it was where it got real bad
before the Internet.
Exactly.
There was a time before the Internet
now.
Exactly.
I mean,
yeah,
we became friends before the Internet.
How about that?
We even get ahold of each other.
We call each other on the phone.
How to catch you when you're at home
like normally it's right up early.
Make phone calls before you leave the
house.
You remember the first cell phones?
They looked like it could use it as a
billy club here.
This right here.
Driving a gypsy cabs.
One the most dangerous jobs in New York
City.
Since 1990 180 drivers average of two a
month had been
killed while on duty.
Holy Shit.
So it wasn't foreign and there's one 80.
I mean maybe it was or not.
Not a 440,
but maybe that was one 80 when they
stopped counting during the time this
article is written because this is,
they're talking about 1990.
I was living in New York when this was
happening and I kind of moved there
around then so it could have gotten even
worse.
Do you ever miss it?
Do me neither.
You know you get the guys from New York.
I like the Kennedy's stand.
How you could make it here.
It's awesome.
Don't get me wrong.
I think I could adapt.
I think if I decided to live in New York
tomorrow,
I'd love it.
I don't think it's bad.
I don't miss your kids and the whole
thing is hard,
but you know what man?
I mean,
kids can grow up anywhere.
They really can't.
I just don't know if it's ideal when
you're rather than being walking around
where you live.
Then honestly,
I think really it's better probably in a
non showbiz related city.
I think just being in the city,
it's probably not healthy for kids.
I think kids are better off in places
like Seattle,
which is even if it's showbiz related,
it's not television,
film related.
Like I feel like the television and film
world is filled with so many people out
here and done me wrong.
I'm not saying it's a bad business.
I was in it for a long time.
Not that I don't mean anything against
it,
but I just think that the kind of people
that it attracts,
not all of them,
but a good amount of them are really
crazy and they're real needy and they
value the value of certain type of fame
with it gets.
It gets really crazy.
We were talking about last night with
the girls to come in the store and
Sophie,
Sophie or Sophia Africa.
She said to me,
she didn't want to tell me she was an
actress.
She was embarrassed.
Decision in funny because well,
you know,
it's like I was doing the thing on stage
the other night about we need more
actors and actresses.
If you know anybody back east that wants
to be an actor,
tell them to come out here.
But it's sad when you're embarrassed to
say what you want to be.
There's nothing wrong with doing it,
so that's the problem.
Like do acting itself,
does nothing wrong with it.
As long as the lead.
I'm saying something wrong with the
profession.
It's just there's a giant number of
people who come out here that are just
absolutely bat shit crazy.
I know and they want.
They just want everybody to like us.
The other thing too,
there's like a lack of a.
it's very difficult when people are
judging you,
it's like there's a problem with the
entire design of the audition process
because you're creating people that are
going to be exactly what you want them
to be because those are the people that
you're going to hire,
so it becomes an incredibly left wing
environment.
It becomes real,
which is great and a lot of ways it
balances things out.
But our culture is driven primarily from
things from the left good things that
compassionate stuff like,
you know,
gay rights and gay marriage and a lot of
other like left wing type ideas that I
agree with that I think are great.
But it's 100 percent driven by that.
So these people,
if they have different opinions,
it's very difficult for them to express
it and still work like so you get a lot
of people that are terrified of stepping
on anybody's toes.
So they say a bunch of nonsense.
Like you ever talk to people that don't
say nice to meet you because they're
worried they might have already met you.
Right.
You know what I mean?
So they,
you know what they say?
They say nice to see you.
Well,
you know what I covered.
You know what?
I never did a people.
I never asked him what's up or what's
going on.
I know that about here because people
feel guilty like they have to recite in
what's going on in their lives.
This whole resume.
And I'd rather them just say,
hey man,
you know,
it's good to see you.
And that's the end of the things like,
I don't want to put.
Oh,
I got a lot of irons in the sound from
the impractical jokers.
Yeah.
He was out here one night.
He goes,
it's before they really hit.
yeah,
I got nothing going on.
I said,
never say that in Hollywood.
I'm fucking when we got here,
here's what you say.
I got a lot of irons in the fire.
I don't want to jinx it.
Taste better when it comes through.
Big plans in the works.
Check my instagram page for future
notifications.
When you said you're really not part of
that part of the business anymore,
it's funny that you're so busy you don't
have time to do a movie.
Yeah,
kind.
Kinda cool.
The only movies I've ever done it the
Kevin James Movies,
so I didn't have to audition.
Yeah,
of course.
Got Me Parts.
You shouldn't have addition edition
should if you want something good.
But the process itself is the problem
with it.
Not necessarily for me who's a
financially independent,
but the process for a lot of people
aren't who are desperately needing
something to employ them.
So they can apply their craft,
so I don't need anybody to employ me so
that I could do standup.
Neither do we just do it and we don't
need anybody to employ us to do this
podcast.
We just do it.
You just do yours.
I just do my.
We all just do our own shit.
And because of that you don't.
You could be you.
You can actually be you.
Oh,
the suits have lost so much power in the
last 10 years.
Yeah.
Well we're also starting to see like
what this,
what is this world really about?
It's about generating income.
That's it.
It's not about art.
That's why reality shows took off like
crazy.
Well,
your generation is much better than mine
as far as business people.
You guys,
your group is smart,
you know,
so.
Well,
you know,
you learn how to use social media to
your advantage.
You
know,
Tom,
a lot of it was luck.
A lot of it was locked.
Some of it was copying Dane Cook to do
some of it was definitely that.
I was already doing stuff online,
but I wasn't doing stuff.
I was writing blogs and I was doing
certain things,
so just as like a little exercise like
to just to come up with ideas and just
to get my writing flowing.
So I write a write a lot of blogs back
then and Dane Cook,
I didn't have the mind space and you
started using it to promote shows and it
just,
it was crazy how much it blew him up.
He was an early adopter and he was the
perfect guy for it,
you know,
cute high energy girls loved him and it
was like he was like one of the first
comics that had like a bunch of girl
fans.
It was like a rock and roll guy.
Very,
very interesting times.
But it,
I think it woke up everybody to the
power of social media and then twitter
came along of course.
But
the podcast thing was totally lucky,
man.
If it wasn't for just um.
Yeah,
but you had to be good at a gentleman to
sell it too much.
I wasn't good at in the beginning.
If you go back and listen to some of
those early ones are fucking terrible.
Well remember we were talking at the
Improv Cusco and I said to you,
uh,
and I didn't want you to think I was
hitting,
hitting me,
hitting to get onto the show,
but I said,
I said to you,
uh,
if you do one of your shows,
it's better than doing all the late
night shows in one week.
Oh,
as far as like the mosher.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm doing,
I'm going to Australia tomorrow and
those people are going to be thrilled
that I'm going,
that I'm on the podcast because I was in
New Zealand and people listen to you
there,
you know,
it's an incredible.
Nobody,
nobody watches the tonight show in
Australia.
That's crazy.
The could show.
Yeah.
Podcasts are nuts,
man.
It's,
you can get them easy.
That's the thing about it.
If you have to watch the tonight show to
catch you,
the odds of you actually being in front
of your television when that happens are
small.
The odds of you dvr in this night show
or also small,
you know,
it's usually one of those things where a
lot of people look forward to it and
they watched it before they go to bed.
It's a normal ritual.
I only use that as an example.
We couldn't,
but it's a good one.
It's a good example because that's what
we always needed,
right?
I mean Carson was the thing back when
you were coming up,
if you got on Carson,
Holy Shit,
you fucking made it and then you would
see a guy like Richard January 18
carson's or something like that and you
are brilliant and just such a great
comic.
And you would,
you'd see those,
those credits and you go,
Jesus Christ,
I got did Carson 18 times.
Then you would go see him.
And of course he was at the time when I
first saw jenny was like in the
eighties.
He was a master a master.
I remember just being in awe and there
was a bunch of other comedians that were
at the,
uh,
east side comedy club member,
east side in Long Island.
Richard Mediterranean.
Yup.
Richmond Vini,
me and Kevin James,
we're sitting around after the show and
we're shaking her head.
We're like,
God damn,
he's good.
God dammit.
He apparently did two different hours on
a Friday night.
He did two shows and eight and 10 to two
completely different hours,
completely top to bottom,
and they were like both of them or
slaughtering his.
Just a destroyer.
Brilliant writer.
I remember feeling like when he.
He could take premises that you didn't
think there was anything there and you
can turn them into like one of your
favorite bits,
like you did a premise about buying a
corvette and the guy trying to talk them
into all sorts of stuff in the corvette.
And I remember thinking while he was
doing this,
wow,
how's this guy going to make this funny?
Yeah.
Talking about buying an expensive sports
car and he's gonna figure out how to
make this funny.
Remember the Rep thing?
He did.
I had a bunch of football.
We didn't know he had problems with him
and I and it really was because of him
and let's say,
and they couldn't because he's dead now,
but what happened was we were like
getting different things at the same
time,
you know,
with each other.
Well,
he was competitive with me and I think
because people pitted us against each
other purely because we were short
Italians,
the short Italian as well,
but you've never been nothing but
supportive and nice
to meet you.
Joseph,
you know,
one time I said to him,
because somebody was talking about,
I said,
why don't we go out on the road
together?
Oh yeah,
we'll fill up theaters.
And he goes,
why would I want to do that?
I said,
I don't know.
Make money to have fun.
You know,
he didn't understand the concept.
He said to me one time,
he goes,
Montreal comedy festival,
you think I should go there?
I said,
go with the idea that you're going to
meet beautiful girls.
Go to great restaurants and if you
happen to get a deal you do but have
fun.
And he goes,
fine.
He looked at me like,
what do you mean fun?
This isn't fun.
It's just he was tortured.
He never enjoyed it.
That's the saddest part of it.
He was seeing never knew how good he was
there.
He never enjoyed how good he was.
I first met him in Montreal.
Yeah.
I first met him in like,
well,
isn't that where I met you?
Yup.
I met him in 94 just so we were both
passing each other and in the front
doors just said,
hi.
Hey Man.
Nice to meet you,
blah blah blah,
blah,
blah.
What shows you doing that kind of thing.
Just,
you know,
and it seemed to me like he just was a,
just a brilliant,
brilliant mind.
Like I'm always thinking,
but just always,
you know,
someone had maybe almost too much.
I saw him on a plane.
I was getting.
I was flying back.
Remember they had three cabins and the
American notice in first class he was in
coach with Lenny,
Lenny Clarke.
No,
law clerk.
Linny Africanus.
Lenny Shoultz.
Crazy.
Lenny crazy.
No,
not that crazy land.
More pigs.
More shit later.
Somebody fucking Lenny's income.
But what other,
Lenny Dave,
Hawthorne,
Hawthorne's friend,
he would know them.
But anyway,
uh,
he spent,
I walked back to say hi and he goes,
I usually play first myself,
but I'm plying him.
I said,
it's okay.
I went,
it's all right.
I didn't fly.
ABC flew me and he didn't like that
either.
I'm thinking I didn't do that to rub it
in.
And then I finally said to him,
rich,
what do you want me to do?
You want my cookie?
I'm just in first class.
It's not a big fucking deal.
You guys are so Italian.
That's such a fucking
good Chalami over there.
That fucking Salamis get tonight treads.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's a tough.
It's a tough lesson for those guys that
are super competitive and loaners.
It's a tough lesson as you start getting
older that none of this shit is fun if
you don't have friends.
Yeah.
You know what we're talking about.
Last night we were all hanging out is
you and me,
crusher and Josh Martin and all the
Jessie Mae Peluso.
We're all hanging out.
She's great.
She's so great.
But we're all laughing.
And having a great time and you know,
we're,
we're all comics,
you know,
that's supposed to be like that.
It's supposed to be.
We see each other,
we hug each other,
I get excited.
I remember when I went to see the
premiere of a Batman,
the very first one and Jack Nicholson
was in it and he was at the bar and just
fucking drinking.
It's cheers where everybody in prince
was there.
Just little,
little kind of faggoty.
Prince are you say faggoty shit
now.
But anyway,
he's sitting there.
Joe,
he's got two body guards sitting in
front of me sitting there and he's not.
I'm thinking,
what fun is it?
Why don't you talk to somebody feels
like royalty though.
I mean the guy named himself prints.
How shocking is that?
He wants to be treated like royalty with
giant men guarding his flesh by the way.
He's got to get in my car.
I have an idea.
He had some high heels on too.
I guess he wrote the music for that.
But anyway,
it just struck me about here's Nicholson
easily just as famous if not more than
him.
And he was like,
miserable,
Nicholson's all having fun.
Well yeah,
some people don't know me,
but it's also part of what we were
talking about earlier.
You were talking about Brian and you
were saying that a colby,
as he's gotten older,
it's become more humble and how
convenient then when he's not doing good
and the legs and gaining their
personality.
But that could be the case,
but it also could be the case,
couldn't it?
That he's maturing as a man and learning
and absolutely lies against mistakes and
the consequences of his actions and
maybe reflecting on his behavior and
change who he is that's being alone with
all your money.
What are you gonna do put your money in
your bed and lay on it.
But those extreme winters,
extreme winters are so fucking hyper
crazy competitive.
Like.
Well,
when I was talking to Lance Armstrong,
it was really sinking in because I know
guys like him.
I know guys like him.
Whether it's,
you know,
fighters for the most part like you,
you like I know guys from the UFC dark.
They're extreme winters.
They know how to win.
And one of the ways to know how to win,
you got to say fuck everybody else.
And those guys did say fuck everybody
else like that in the world of art,
you know,
comedy and things along those lines.
It's like,
it's not necessary.
It's,
it fucks up.
It's not basketball.
We have to intimidate your opponent.
Like it's better for everybody if you're
nice to each other.
You know?
I never felt that somebody else's
success diminished me.
Yeah.
Like when I first started out,
Eddie Murphy was at the same time he was
getting these movies and some fucking
Guido,
because there's no,
I'm not,
don't bother you.
Any movers getting these movies and you
were here at bananas.
I go,
what the fuck does it have to do with
me?
Do you think if he didn't get 48 hours I
would have gotten it.
Yeah.
You know,
that mentality is just a loser
mentality.
And it all it is,
is a pattern.
You let your brain go down that path.
There's a pattern of behavior,
like you recognize that somebody else
has something,
you want that something and then you'd
be upset.
That person has it and then you don't,
and it becomes this animal instinct
thing.
It's like a jealousy.
I mean,
Chimpanzees Have Horrible Jealousy,
dop,
real horrible jealousy.
That guy that got his face bit off and
it's difficult often.
Remember that guy I didn't remember.
I remember a woman getting her face.
There was a woman who did,
but before the woman who did see the
woman who did it was because her friend
had the champ and the woman who lived
with the champ had some weird
relationship with the champion.
She slept with it.
She gave him a Xanax and she gave him
red wine,
so he's fucking chimp was drunk and on
pills
and he ripped this lady's face off.
So that's one chimp or had been drunk
and on pills,
that's one champ.
But then there was another champ with
this guy had a pet chimp and he went to
visit his pet chimp and the chimp got to
be a certain age.
They had to get rid of it cause it was
biting people and it was terrifying.
Right?
I think a bit someone's finger off so
they.
Because that's what they do.
The grab your hand,
they bite your finger off,
they tear your finger from your hand and
they do it like almost instantly.
That's the move.
Um,
if you're lucky,
if they don't go for your face left
southern,
lift me then with the squirrel monkey.
Once I was,
before I was in first grade,
I was so kindergarten kid,
just me and this squirrel monkey started
fucking hissing at me.
Oh,
I was fucking terrified.
My grandmother had a monkey.
They lived in a base,
hit a squirrel monkey.
It was called Chichi gum chew gum.
It was like open up gum wrappers and
chew gum,
gets a monkey fucking out of their mind.
So anyway,
these people,
they went to visit their pet chimp at
the sanctuary because they still loved
them.
They had a relationship with this champ,
you know,
and they're like,
we can't be with you anymore,
but we're coming to visit.
And when they came to visit,
they dropped off cake.
They gave him a cake,
a birthday cake.
And the other chimps got furious that
this chimp got cake and that they didn't
and someone fucked up and left something
open and they got out and when they got
out they tore this guy apart just
because he gave cake to this one guy and
he didn't give it to him.
So they tore his dick off towards
fingers off.
But it's face off.
They just tear you apart.
Uh,
they bought all your fingers off.
They don't give a fuck.
They're monsters.
I was on one of those shows.
Pet store or one.
Remember that?
The way the judge,
different animal tricks.
No,
it's holding a baby gorilla.
I mean really young.
But I mean I thought that this thing is
going to be so fucking powerpoint.
It was just like a baby put his head on
my shoulder and started making out with
it.
It was nice.
Well,
gorillas are more peaceful,
I think a real other than chimps.
Chimps are crazy serve way more violent.
I mean,
they're all violent.
They're all vital.
I mean,
gorillas are vegetarians.
It pretty much exclusively.
So when you see a gorilla and those
giant fangs that they have,
that's just for fighting nothing else.
So they've definitely fight each other,
especially the males.
There was a video of a zoo recently.
These two males beating the shit out of
each other and some wildlife preserve
crazy.
See how strong they are.
It's just weird that they're like our
size but stronger tens.
I'm stronger with every way.
Heavier.
Full grown grown like 500 pounds or
something crazy.
I think that makes sense.
Yeah,
I think they get even bigger.
Would it?
How big is the biggest silver back
gorilla?
If you had to guess,
would you guys?
Seven hundred pounds.
Wow.
It sort of gets ruined by $400.
That's big.
I'm going to go with five,
500 pounds.
I'll take the.
I'll take the under.
You might be right though.
It might be like 800 or something.
I don't know.
I'm excited to find the results.
Oddly that Jamie,
I
found a gorilla named titus.
I'm trying to find out if it's a
documentary named titus,
the gorilla king.
I'm trying to find the size.
This is not helping me.
Jamie,
Google Gorillas,
mountain gorilla,
gorilla.
Just Google gorilla.
You go to Wikipedia and it tells you
exactly how much grill is way gorilla.
Gorilla Cook.
I'm saying 500 pounds.
I'm saying a full grown grill is 500
pounds.
That's what I'm going with that I think
I went over to for 700.
You might not.
I'm going to number eight for some
reason is in my head.
Eight hundred pounds is in my head.
Are they 800 pound gorilla?
It was something that was 3,500 pound
gorilla,
right?
Wasn't that what they always said?
I don't know the 500 pound gorilla in
the room.
Oh,
wasn't it like the elephant in the room?
Five hundred pound gorilla was the one
who could do anything.
You want
about 510 pounds in the wild.
Vizio.
No beast.
White gorilla knowledge.
Hey.
All my people,
I was thinking like Comedians,
like are smart.
Some of them I was with the dumbest
fucking group of Comedians that live
fact the other night.
First of all,
they go,
uh,
I'm going to Australia tomorrow.
I told you that the Sydney Festival in
Perth,
in Australia.
Anyway,
they said,
how far is it?
One of the guys?
I said,
uh,
from Sydney to La.
Sydney is 7,000 miles because Xero like,
oh yeah.
What'd you think?
He goes,
I thought it was a couple of hundred
thousand miles.
Ten thousand miles.
How far?
What's the circumference of the earth?
He goes,
I don't know.
A couple hundred thousand.
No,
it's 24,000 miles.
Something that they didn't know
anything.
Joe,
that,
which I was like so fly and I'm not
going to take us,
you know,
all these guys.
One Guy said,
I said,
well,
how far do you think the earth is from
the son?
He Gun,
I don't know,
like 4,000.
5,000.
Well,
the sun is 93 million miles and we still
get a sunburn like this wizard.
Yeah,
you're Carl Sagan all of a sudden.
That's hilarious.
That's funny.
A couple late years.
Some people don't even consider the fact
that we're on a giant 24,000 mile ball
and we get cocky as if a kid just
dressed,
but if it dropped two feet,
we'd all feel it.
We will if we get hit with something.
That's just the thing that gets me.
Did you see that recent impact they
spotted on Jupiter?
They watched a comic collab with
Jupiter.
Who?
A comic.
No.
Yeah,
he was up there bombing.
They hired him for a corporate gig.
You do corporate gigs.
Dom?
Not many
too.
I've had people crying.
I'm the president of a company with a
wipe was crying,
which are really good.
It's not.
It's not for me.
Grow Up,
bitch.
You what?
The corporate,
right?
Just do your
own thing.
It's not worth it.
Somebody just offered you when a buddy
of mine who works in a company and it
would be a cool Gig,
be involved,
but you know what I,
you know,
it's always a keywords but it's got to
keep it clean,
but it's not much money.
Hey,
why don't you go fuck you.
So why do you ever see my standup?
Brian Cowen did one recently.
Yeah,
but he could do it,
but the guy told him right before he was
doing this thing and he was,
this is a different story,
but it wasn't a,
it was a benefit.
That's what it is.
Okay.
He did a benefit and right before he was
like,
you know,
it's a non standup environment.
That's how it's connected.
It's doing a standup comedy show in
something that's other than a standup
comedy show,
you know,
so if it's got some sort of an auction,
some benefit or something like that.
And he was a part of it.
It was some dude,
he knows it's famous.
So he goes and right before he's about
to go on,
they tell him to keep it pg.
They tell them keep it.
PG is a lot of religious people here.
Keep it pg and me.
It's like what?
Like,
wait,
what are you saying?
You're saying you,
you,
you want me to come out here and do
stand up,
but you want me to keep it like you're
gonna tell me this right before I go on
stage.
Like I have an alternative set,
like you know,
Brian is an hour that he does everywhere
on the road.
He's got it honed down to a science and
that's what he's ready to do and right
before he's ready to do that,
they come to him and tell him to keep
it.
That's ridiculous.
You know what?
I hate you a little blue.
You can be a little blue.
What the fuck does that mean?
Don't hire some.
So relative.
Don't.
Don't ask him to go.
If you don't know what someone like,
if you want to hire Gary Clark Jr,
but you want to play the fiddle.
He doesn't play the fucking fiddle.
Stupid.
He's a guitar.
I mean he probably does if he wants to.
If we want it to me.
Yeah,
but you hire.
You're hiring Gary Clark junior to do
Gary Clark Jr.
That's where you start.
That's what you want them to do,
right?
You don't ask them to fucking sing like
adele.
It's stupid to try to get an r rated
comic like callan and tell him to be pg
right before he goes on stage.
That's rude.
He's not even that dirty,
but he's definitely not pg.
He Talks a lot about a lot of caulk.
Yeah.
A lot of busy work at it.
I can't tell he does like a dancer,
but I love to fuck with him.
I know he gets it,
but he's.
He's plays along with it,
but also actually gets insulted at the
same.
It's still hurt his feelings.
He'll play along with it.
Talk about himself and I'm built for
dance.
I'm bill.
I'm more like a woman.
And you go,
yeah,
yeah.
Like a we'll womanly like a woman,
like now hip,
so it would have to have a cesarean
section and the,
you a hits them like,
whoa,
that doesn't feel good.
I remember I told,
I told him,
joe,
that says,
you know,
it's interesting the way you're standing
up as a.
You don't particularly go for the laugh,
you know,
you don't pander to the crib,
but trying to like entertain the middle
and he was going to fuck with me a
little bit.
Then he goes,
brian,
I'm kidding.
But I got them a little joey diaz pulled
his dick out on stage once and tom turns
to me and goes,
I see he's been writing again.
That was fucking funny.
It's funny.
I mean that's another example.
Like of friendship.
Joey diaz,
you know joe,
he loves everybody who's around.
Joey loves joey and everybody in joey
circle.
Joey's in a circle of love.
Like if you talked to joel or anybody
like with its least siad or any of the
people that he knows and the people that
he's around with all the time.
Or it's me.
You're dunking or ari.
Everybody loves him.
So he's around love and support all the
time.
I love his phone call.
She get them to write equals me is the
only instance.
Ms dot maria.
You okay?
Yeah.
Joe,
how you doing?
Good.
All right baby.
I'll talk to you later.
Yeah.
He calls people up to tell you he loves
you.
Just checks in on you.
He's a jam.
What a fucking killer acting.
You never know.
he was murdered in santa barbara to
woof.
He plants his feet there and he fucking
kills god.
Damn.
He's.
He's hot right now.
Damn.
You know joe is,
he's on fire.
He puts out a lot of material to joe.
He's always working on some new stuff,
you know,
just always working on some news.
He found this,
he found his voice,
you know?
Oh yeAh.
And he's also like really popular right
now.
LIke joey is selling out theaters.
Are you selling out the wilbur in
boston?
He's a,
he,
he can sell out a lot of pretty big
places right now.
Sells out comedy clubs like crazy so
people know what they're getting into.
They're looking forward to seeing them
and when joey feels comfortable,
like he's the most funniest when he's
around like us.
So yeah,
because he's the most comfortable
because he just surrounded by love and
then they'll start talking shit and then
you'll be crying.
Next thing you know you're crying,
you know,
but now that he gets that everywhere he
goes now because for years he had to get
these people to like him before he could
be uncle joey.
He had to get them to like him and that
was part of the struggle was getting
these people to understand what is in
front of them.
They're looking at this 300 pound Cuba
and talking about eating asshole.
You got to eat.
Am I right?
Am I right ladies?
My floor.
And they're like,
what the fuCk?
They don't know what to expect and they
didn't plan on seeing that.
So it takes a while,
but now that you plan on seeing it and
you know you're going to see them.
Then joey diaz,
if you go to a joey diaz show,
you go see him perform.
It's all joey diaz fans and it's
beautiful.
Beautiful.
We're splitting the bill at the ice
house.
Yeah,
last year.
A few times.
there's so much.
His fans are so much fun.
Yeah.
And fans of his will be fans of you and
fans of you be fans of his.
It's a great combination.
What?
I mean,
he's exactly what I'm talking about.
The guy,
he made it because he's.
He's good,
but he got exposure on the internet.
It wasn't.
It wasn't through the regular.
The old channels with the tonight show
or hbo special or any of that shit?
No,
they were,
they were all upset that it wasn't
happening that way.
Um,
ari was real upset about that are we was
real disgusted at one point in time by
the old regime at comedy central and he
was like,
they kept the same fucking
people.
I'll never geT in there.
and meanwhile now he's got a show in the
second season on comedy central and
everything about it,
like all the stuff that kicked off,
kicked off because of the internet,
the amazing racist stuff that he did and
then ruin.
He used to do ask a jew at the comedy
store.
He said he was on my podcast,
joe.
And he goes,
what is it about me that look so jewish?
I said,
I dunno,
you know,
he's just being a little.
I'm jewish,
right?
You know,
I'm a jew by looking at me.
I said,
what is the definitive features that.
Go aHead.
I don't know.
Your eyes,
your nose.
I don't,
I don't really want to break it down.
Your hair.
Jews a weird one because it's a
religion.
But it's also a race,
like we say,
a guy looks jewish.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you don't say guy looks catholic,
but you can be jewish.
The mayor of Ireland was jewish and he
had red hair and blue eyes.
The mayor of Ireland was jewish.
Mayor of dublin rather.
Really?
Yeah.
How can we be a mayor of violence?
You know what?
Size of a state they should get stopped
being all high and mighty.
Come over the United States folks.
I'll be in cacao.
Thailand.
I'll be in the may.
June.
Find people.
Man,
I would love to have you.
But I was telling you about me and bird
over there crying.
Lift and you were talking about our.
I've done dublin a couple times and I
did a northern Ireland.
Belfast.
Love it up there.
It's fun.
They're fun people,
man.
They're why I had a conversation with
this fucking guy in a bar in belfast.
We were both hammered,
but he was.
He was talking in a different language.
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not exaggerating.
I barely understood what he was talking
because they don't open their mouth like
the north north of Ireland and scotland
are very similar.
that would.
A lot of the demo opened their mouth
when they talk,
so you can't even lip read and all he
kept saying was,
I'll fight any man.
That's all I could hear.
I'm fight any man because I knew we were
here for the ufc because
I check my data.
Any man.
I just kept repeating himself.
Mike.
All rigHt dude.
Okay.
Go fight any man.
Good luck with all that.
I didn't know what to tell them how to
fight.
Anyone hammered eyes rolling around in
his head.
Just prided himself on the beating that
he can take in.
Glasgow is doing it to show and this
woman I couldn't understand her and the
stage manager.
I said,
I'm sorry.
Excuse me in front of.
She goes appeal.
We have a language,
bobby.
I said,
we just started laughing and then just
got a translator for me.
A translator speak english.
Well,
yeah.
Have you ever see trainspotting?
Yeah.
Movie that they have the subtitles,
even though they're all speaking english
through either a smart because it's hard
to understand that for us.
Yeah,
they do that a lot on like reality shows
and stuff.
TheY'll put in subtitles.
People are whispering about shit,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
But um,
the fact that the slang or the waY they
talk in northern Ireland,
their dialect is so much different than
american english,
but they can understand us.
Like if I'm tAlking like this,
everybody can understand me.
Right.
But they grew up on our media,
but then talking to that and fashion is
a thing that there's a difference
between the way the doctors are already.
Otherwise I mushed together.
It's pretty good.
They're smushed.
we're,
we're lazier with our words.
But do you understand that they grew up
watching the sopranos and seinfeld,
we didn't grow up watching father ted or
any of those english or irish shows now.
Well,
top gear,
top gear with jeremy clarkson.
Richard hammered.
Oh,
what's his name?
Richard hammond and something.
James may.
Yeah.
A great show.
I vaguely remember that.
But jeremy clarkson's,
one of the funniest guys on tv in
england who's hilarious,
hilarious,
just a car reviewer and just as a writer
and a guy reviewed cars,
love cars,
but he,
uh,
he punched his producer.
They canceled the show apparently.
I don't know what happened.
Human,
the guy I've made up,
but they're already fired him,
so I'm now they're going to do it on
amazon now than to do the same show,
but they have to come up with a new name
for it because jeremy clarkson has been
talking about it and it won't come out.
It will be more than a year from the
time they fired him before this new one
comes out.
Maybe contractual stuff.
But the,
in that time they hired a whole new crew
of top gear and I wonder how the new
crews doing the new crew of top gear was
on Arizona.
Who was it?
Chris evans is on it.
I don't know.
Google it.
You asked me what am I a fucking
chris evans and matt lewis.
Matt leblanc from friends in england?
No,
the tv show friends.
Right in england.
He's doing copier in england.
Jamie,
you stoned.
What's goIng on?
A little bit here.
A little out of it.
No,
I'm telling you.
Chris evans,
the joe.
I did twice.
oh,
did right before the show.
How dare you?
chris evans being straight youtube car
guy.
He's one of the host on the show to
england.
Yeah,
he was on the podcast and matt leblanc
from friends.
He's.
There's seven people that are on it.
Seven people on the new english block in
england.
So it was matt leblanc live in england.
No,
don't know.
Well there is number three.
How weird.
Well that's interesting that they
decided to go completely crazy and put
six hosts instead of three.
Yes.
I'm sure they just team up to do
different challenges like they did
before,
but who are.
Who is everybody there for the rest of
the people on to.
It looks like lebron james or the
airline.
Adam
james with the air let out.
There's no list of the names.
No,
I hear.
Hmm.
It's weird.
This is on what?
Bbc?
Yep.
Boy,
they got fucking boring television.
Find out what,
what the cast is because who was that
one guy in the background?
There's not chris harris.
Ah,
that's what I was trying.
No,
chris evans.
you mean chris harris?
The guy that was on the podcast game.
You said the wrong name was chris evans.
I don't know why I keeps saying chris
evans everywhere.
Is that his name was chris harris?
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
Is it you show the same guy?
Maybe it's chris evans and not chris
harris.
I'm sure they probably know his name.
Sorry.
This is obviously.
It's a different guy.
WHo is this a?
We'll just go to just google.
Chris evans.
Let's see what the fuck's going on here.
Get to the bottom of this.
God damn it.
Jesus christ our era.
I hardly remember that show.
We'll get a photo of this gentleman.
So we'll see.
It looks like chris evans.
That's not chris harris.
So chris harris is the guy that was on
here?
Yes.
Is he on this new show?
Maybe they're both on it and that's why
I'm confused.
It looks like it.
That's chris harris,
right?
Yes.
This must be confirmed.
So he's one of the new top gear host.
Aha.
All right,
that makes sense.
So that's chris evans,
who's the redheaded gentlemen.
And then there's chris harris who's been
on the show.
Oh,
well that might work.
That fucking guy's hilarious.
Harris is hilarious.
He's really funny,
man.
He was really fucking smart to really
smart.
What's his ethnic background?
So she's a,
she's a german.
I think she's like a bmw driver.
This girl's been schmidts.
The middle guy looks familiar to me.
Like you get out driver even though
you're a man,
don't you feel like there's something
about you though when maybe.
I mean I just got
tear it up.
I got my own business.
So basically I'm a race car driver.
take turns.
He's a that chris harris guys.
Awesome though his series.
Chris harris on cars on youtube.
like one of the best,
uh,
reviews of automobiles.
He's like one of the most thorough,
one of the most humorous and so educated
and knowledgeable about the inner
workings of a car and why certain
aspects of a car affect other aspects of
it and like what's good and what's bad.
He's just a wizard man.
He's really good.
He's a perfect guy to replace jeremy
clarkson because it's humor is also very
british.
It's not as insulting as jeremy clarkson
tend to be and probably not as like go
for the punchline is jeremy clarks,
clarks,
and has some hilarious punchlines.
He's a really funny guy,
man.
HIs reviews of cars were awesome.
It was like I watch it and just fast
forward through the other shit until he
would get to a car because he's just
fun.
What was it on here?
It was on bbc America.
Okay.
But,
uh,
there's a top gear and then there's a
top gear from here,
uh,
with uh,
rutledge who was here.
Um,
and um,
our buddy adam ferraris on it.
Tanner foust,
that's the show.
Adams on.
He's on the american version,
the american version of top gear
finally.
Okay.
We love you,
adam.
There we go.
Chris harris,
a youtube star.
they're calling them chris harris.
f one pundit eddie Jordan,
motoring journalists.
Rory read and chris evans and matt and
the stig show returns in may.
Interesting.
So it's returning next montH.
Hmm.
She looked mad if harris is on it and
they let him do his thing,
it'll be awesome.
Matt leblanc grew up.
Grew up in my town.
Really?
Yeah.
He grew up in newton.
I,
uh,
heard about him when I moved here.
I think we dated the same girl at one
point in time when we were young,
like when we're like teenage years or
something like that.
Say mitch?
I think so.
I'm 48.
I think he's 48,
two or something close to it.
Uh,
but yeah,
he's from newton.
He's from newton,
Massachusetts.
He's 48.
Yeah.
I never meT that dude though.
It's what?
John katz lips.
Dr cat.
How's he doing?
Is he doing okay?
Is that right?
It's still having some nerve problems
where those nerves and mess,
at least I don't need as a motherfucker
always was.
He was the host of the first open mic
night I ever did.
Really?
He's not the kind of guy that should be
hosting.
He was great.
Was it good?
Yeah,
he was great.
I mean it was a pro.
Knew what he was doing.
He's a pro,
but as it stitches comedy club in
boston,
1988.
August 27th.
We were talking about garry shandling,
you know,
august,
28th,
19,
August 27th,
88 today.
The garry shandling man.
So sad with john was telling me about
ally and he said on the,
on dr katz,
he said,
it's important when you're making little
dual woman that you end at the same
time.
And gary said,
no,
actually it's more important to begin.
Same time
that you begin making love at the same
time,
you know?
Yes.
It's typical john,
dr katz kind of joke.
It's just not hitting me.
Whatever reason I can't pay you.
So that's why I said It was their job
to take.
Maybe it's coming out of your mouth.
I'm expecting be as funny is what you
come up with dom.
They could show you.
It's how,
you know what I mean brother.
Appreciate it.
My pleasure.
Trying to write.
You know that you want.
Well,
you're always reading.
You're uh,
you're one of those guys that's.
You're always enjoying the process.
You know,
I think the funniest people that I know
are all the ones like you are ds or
birth or any,
any of those guys that are just
constantly turning out new stuff,
constantly working out,
putting on stuff that made me feel good
a few weeks ago when you were in because
I hear you.
I hear you laughing.
I heard I heard mark marin lift.
He was laughing.
I was crying though.
You are killing me.
You went up guns blazing.
It was funny too because you were
falling christina and she had this bed.
I won't give away the bit but you went
on after her mocking the premise of the
bit deeper,
deeper,
deeper into it too.
It was so preposterous.
I was fun.
That fucking place is so much fun.
I like to fuck around with the other
acts when they're my friends,
you know,
that's the one thing I used to like in
the old lift factory days when brian was
still coming in there and,
and kristala was new and we'd get up in
the balcony and just harass each other.
Yeah,
that was fun man.
I haven't been back to the laugh factory
except for your shows and a long time,
but I did a show there the other night
on a.
He did a benefit or something like that.
on what day was it?
Tuesday.
Um,
but damn it was good.
Cool crowd was on fire,
man.
Yeah,
I did one other set there to,
for another guy.
I did the John Henson show and then I
did like a wednesday night.
That was,
it was packed.
It was great.
So they have a good room in vegas for
first time I heard,
but brad garrets,
they say it's better the brad garret
room with the mgm parents,
but political reasons I don't want to
make a choice but like what you're doing
there,
but I will just nod your head to the
left if you think brad gets better or to
look to look at him.
Big folks.
Good.
YeAh.
But the brad garrett one.
I've yet to be while you have to walk
inside,
either one of them is beautiful.
We've got to organize a time where we're
both in vegas at the same time.
Know I love that.
How often do you do that room?
Uh,
I'm doing it in july.
I'm doing brad's in june.
What time's your show when you do it
there?
Brad is only one show.
I think it's at nine.
At nine.
Well,
if that's the case,
you could go to the ufc and still make
it to your show.
Go to the ufc and just leave at eight.
I had so much fun and especially one of
the most compelling sam's they've ever
heard of emotion.
Was that when in montreal when you
invited tammy and I there that was made.
I forget the guy's name.
Very french name.
George.
St pierre.
Yeah man.
Was that fun you got there just in time
for that?
I was so glad he won.
It would have been such a bummer with
that crowd like that,
you know?
Yeah,
man in montreal and then I'm in toronto.
Toronto is the biggest crowd we've ever
had before.
Australia for ufc event which you go,
it shows you a.
Well we've had them in sydney,
but the most recent one was in melbourne
and it was this giant arena that was
huge.
It was more than 60,000,
so it was more than the rogers pLace in.
Was it rod laver?
What's up?
Rod labor.
The tennis guy.
But he has his own.
Uh,
it's like a stadium.
Could be,
could be.
I don't remember.
I don't know that I don't paying
attention to the name of the place,
but it was awesome.
I love melbourne,
melbourne.
It's amazing what a goddamn city.
The and the restaurants are so good and
people aren't really smart too.
It's like someone described it,
bath.
They said it's like a san francisco of
Australia.
Yeah.
So it kind of feels like it is.
I love it there man.
That's one place outside of America.
Other than like vancouver or toronto or
montreal where you go,
oh,
I could live here.
montreal is cold as fuck.
So it was toronto in the winter,
but yeah,
the people are so nice.
It seems like it's almost worth the
trade off.
you know,
Australia,
they're happy.
I think part of it is like they're so
far away from all the trouble.
I mean,
even if you invaded them,
you'd have to stop to refuel.
So ridiculously for.
That's a good point.
None amazing.
He took an island and they filled it up
with criminals and it became an awesome
country.
Yeah.
Then they got some really good lawyers
because the in the aborigines cut a
really bad deal for the rate for the
aborigines.
Well,
he will give me all this shit spots in
the middle of nothing.
Barren land.
It will take the beaches and the clips.
Yeah.
We'll take all the beautiful area and
you guys can have where the spiders
live.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That is definitely a shit deal.
It's just a strange a society.
There's 20 million people in the entire
island and the island where there's more
people in California are just as many.
Yeah.
I want.
I go.
One of the things that's cool about that
is like your own.
When that door opens,
you're in a different world.
The trees are different.
Everything's dip.
I'm going into fall,
you know,
it's,
it's kind of cool.
Have you ever gone to africa?
No.
I've been thinking about going on one of
those wildlife safari in Tanzania where
you,
as long as I know that it's in some sort
of a protected device.
See,
I don't go to any place where you've got
to get needles to go to.
Do you have to go to get needles before
Tanzania?
You don't have to get needles for south
afriCa and I don't know.
Mom was positive.
You don't.
so they have some places in africa we
have to get needles and you have to get
malaria shots and all that.
I think Tanzania is one of them.
I would bet that in Zimbabwe.
Where should I go?
Where's the spot?
I just want to.
I think it would be cool to be
somewhere.
I just don't like those open jeeps,
man.
I don't trust those things I've seen.
I've seen people use those things.
They say the cats don't jump inside.
It's safe and he totally do it,
but bullshit man,
we never did before.
yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
I guess they do it every day and they
know,
you know,
I guess it's probably saved 90 percent
of the time or 99 percent of the time,
but if I could be in something where I
knew that it was completely like closed
off to the outside world,
you can move around amongst them.
I Would tell you that went to Australia
and they had.
I thought I was going to see kangaroos
and all this,
you know,
wallabies,
as the guy says,
you want some food?
I go,
yeah,
I thought,
you know,
you throw the food at the animals and
they're all happy that you go in there
with them.
Right?
You're right there.
They're just like,
there.
You feed them fucking kangaroos when
they get up there pretty big,
you know,
if they want kick you and fuck you up,
break your back.
And I had the punch and emo in the neck.
Oh,
but it was bothering.
Sophia kept nipping at,
or when I hit that motherfucker,
it was very funny because you hear it
was when I hit him,
I really clocked him and
as he ran away,
but I didn't know that you just walked
in with the animals.
Those are dinosaurs,
man.
Oh yeah.
They are.
You know,
they think that a good percentage of
dinosaurs had feathers now
revamp their opinion.
Apparently there's a natural hIstory
museum now that actually has,
I think it's in New York that actually
has a model of a tyrannosaurus with
feathers all over it because they think
it might be what it looked like.
See if you find that jamie,
which kind of makes sense if you think
about them,
mean look,
we see turkeys,
we see these bIg ostriches and he moves
and all these fucking weird giant birds.
Eagles.
They're all dinosaurs and they're
covered with feathers.
There's.
I'm a natural history museum in New York
city model something New York city model
t rex feathers because they actually
have like a life size trx or a model of
tiera.
Large model of tiera might not be life
size,
but It's got feathers all over it.
I'm want to say that it's.
Yeah,
they're starting to think that now.
Starting to think that maybe a lot of
them had feathers.
So how we would send the of the ocean or
we'd descend this,
the land us.
Well,
it's all comes from the original
sources.
Most likely the ocean.
They think that all that life came from
moisture.
Right.
In some,
some weird interaction with proteins and
amino acids.
That radiation.
There it is.
Look at that picture.
Dom,
how crazy is that shit?
What a insane photograph.
But that is Just insane.
So this,
they think this might be with t rex
looks like if you find it,
it's,
it looks like the craziest bird ever.
Like a,
just a demonic bird and it looks fucking
terrifying.
Kinda looks like hair tonight.
We'll just like feathers.
But you're.
Well,
you know there were non flight feathers,
you know
like some birds have different kinds of
feathers.
They,
they know that there was these things
called terror birds that lived in north
America that were enormous.
They were like nine feet tall birds that
didn't live that long ago,
I want to say they lived like a million
years ago.
that's another one.
Another different example of.
That's like a more conservative estimate
of what the feathers looked light,
but there's these comparisons of terror
birds and they put them alongside human
beings and they lived right here to
lived in north America where they don't
have any fossils of them.
They do.
They do have fossils of them and there
were these enormous like nine foot tall
birds but it didn't fly and they just
jacked things,
killed things,
but they had beaks like a bird,
you know,
so because they have beaks like a bird,
we look at that particular type of.
Have a look at that thing.
That's what these things look like.
I mean these were real animals.
The,
the image that we're looking at as a
drawing,
an artist's rendition of a man looks
like a six foot tall man standing next
to a volkswagen with these things
towering above him.
And you get to see how big these
failures there were.
So big.
This one is three meters tall.
So that's nine feet tall.
Fuck you.
Milligrams 400 kilos.
Thousand pounds.
Fifty cm centimeters.
Oh,
because this is awesome.
A different countrY where they speak
some heathen language.
They're called the metric system.
That doesn't seem right.
Fifty centimeters.
That's not that very.
They tried to pull it on us,
but we were two point three meters.
Four hundred kilograms.
He's 50 centimeters the man.
No,
that can't be right.
Is that the man is out there?
Is that the.
No.
What does that mean?
Hmm?
Yeah.
That can be 50 centimeters.
Centimeters like an inch.
It's less than niche,
isn't it?
To be really short guy.
He'd be a tiny bit below that.
Look,
I'll tell you,
compared to a beatles,
beatles,
not very tall.
So maybe he has a short guy maybe,
but put is 50 centimeters as far as.
Because 50 centimeters is above his
head.
I mean as possible.
These two short guides to make a point,
but.
Well yeah.
You know what?
He looks short because look,
if it's nine feet tall,
it's only double his size.
He four and a half feet tall.
Is that a child?
Are they playing with our emotions here?
The fuck is going on.
My point being that fucking thing was
alive.
Fiftieth centimeters is less than two
feet.
It's only 20 inches.
A little dude.
That's not right because the,
the,
the um,
vw bugs,
definitely taller than that picture.
But what year did these things exist?
These terrible words.
Does it say what year?
What a fucking weird world we have as
far as the biological diversity,
you know,
that this is all new to me that we had
these.
I thought we were set on what the
dinosaurs looked like by their bone
structure.
This is not a dinosaur.
This is one point 8 million years ago
from 62 to one point 8 million years
ago.
So if it's from 62 to one point eight,
what does that new findings dating them
to?
Four hundred 50,000 and 17,000 years ago
would imply that some.
Wow,
how do you say that word for us?
Fat for us.
Raw saids forest acids,
forest ras.
it's survived there until recently.
I the late pleistocene.
but this,
this claim is debated.
So it's possible that it was 17,000
years ago,
it's likely that it's somewhere between
that and one point 8 million years ago,
which is like way later than dinosaurs.
The dinosaurs 65 million years ago.
So the oldest date,
they have a 62 million years,
so it's 3 million years newer than the
dinosaurs died.
These monster,
as birds survive that impact.
That's what they are.
They're fucking beasts.
What do you think it hit where they
think it hit the yucatan?
The one that killed the dinosaurs?
they pretty much know where it hit.
They have this whole push out of the
orbit a little.
Well,
they think it did something to the
atmosphere for sure.
They think it rained lava like literally
rained lava.
They think the impact from it clouded
the sky and cause nuclear winter.
I mean the impact had the,
the,
the actual sphere,
the globe.
The earth itself was ringing a bell for
like years.
Look at that.
That's the area.
That's the area where it hit
is what?
Just imagine how big that that means.
That 65 million years ago,
that thing hit and everything started
from scratch.
The whole world got a whole new order.
Everything's different and that can
happen at anytime.
Not only can it happen at anytime,
it's most likely going to happen.
That's why we should ever get too cocky.
Never get too cocky.
You gotta take a leak.
what does that,
what are you showing me?
Uh,
we'll figure it out.
Alright.
Relax.
Dominic.
Area with secret information that he
wrote down.
I had to read his handwriting.
Sorry.
How long before people don't write
things anymore,
but we write that.
We wrote those notes.
People still write little notes.
Yeah.
Well we,
we still text.
Yeah.
It's like we like going to a place when
we see a chalkboard and the menus
written in chocolate.
Oh,
They wrote it themselves.
Well,
they don't teach cursive anymore.
No.
You know you shouldn't.
Did you learn that a.
Yeah.
And catholic to catholic grade school?
No.
I went to catholic.
I went to first grade catholic school
and then the public school after that.
But this was in New York though?
No,
no.
I went New Jersey catholic school and
then san francisco puBlic school after
that.
Then Florida than boston.
We're in Florida,
gaInesville.
Wow.
That'd be tough.
I'd meet you.
I learned something new.
That was when,
when I was a kid,
alligators were endangered and we would
go to this place called lake alice in
gainesville.
We'd feed the alligators marshmallows
and it was weird,
man.
It just didn't worry aBout allIgators.
they were around,
there were always around and they really
didn't bother.
People know they don't,
but there's just this agreement with
people in algiers for whatever fucking
stranger.
He.
It didn't make any sense.
It was almost like evolutionarily it was
a bad idea for them to fuck with people,
so they Just don't bother me.
I don't bother you,
but they woulD occasionally jack
someone's dog.
And when I lived there,
this lady got her poodle snap right off
of her chain.
She was walking by the lady and this
thing just came out.
You see the video I posted on my,
uh,
twitter today.
Some dude send it to me and I retweeted
it.
It's,
um,
this guy's cat fishing and he's a,
he's got these lines set out and you
know,
you,
you have a or it's floating in the
middle of the lake,
a big heavy barbara.
And when you catch catfish,
he just see the bobber move it around.
So you know,
you got one.
So it goes over to the bobber.
Check this out,
don,
look at it.
He pulls it up.
Give us some volume here,
jamie.
We've got a garbage
because he knew it was big.
He thought it was a gar.
Watch this.
Oh my god.
His legs.
Just like a little kid.
Always crying like,
yeah,
of course the kid's crying most.
Get eaten by a dinosaur.
It's calling for mommy.
You can kill it.
Kill the.
That's insane.
Fuck all that.
Look at when it comes up,
watch this.
Oh jesus christ.
It's like a horror movie.
Seeing that thing in that mouth come up.
I was in Costa Rica and I saw some
crocodiles in the wild.
We went on this tour.
He'd get in a boat.
Ooh jesus.
You get in a boat and you see these
crocodiles like lounging themselves on
the border,
on the banks of water,
and then when you're passing by,
they just run and slither into the water
and go under the brown water and you
can't find them.
You don't know where the fuck they are.
It is.
So eerie.
What's the difference between the.
An alligator crocodile is a way more
aggressive.
Way more aggressive.
Yeah.
Those are smaller crocodiles because
they're south american crocodiles.
They're not like nile crocodile.
So there were nile crocodiles.
You wouldn't even want to be in a boat
now.
You definitely wouldn't want to be in
one of those boats.
They'll knock it over now.
They'll fuck you up.
There was a,
um,
I forget what nature magazine,
like national geographic or one of those
types of magazines that had a story
about these kayakers that we're,
uh,
going down a river in the Congo,
I forget what river it was,
but they were going down this river and
this one guy was behind this other guy
in a kayak and you watched the app.
The croc come up,
snap a whole of its jaws,
snap as jaws down in the kayak and then
pull it under like a bobber and flipped
it over and he watched it.
Yeah,
there it is.
Kayaker,
kayakers recount deadly Congo crocodile
attack.
So he flipped over the kayak and then
the kayaks bouncing up and down because
the croc is pulling this guy's body out
of the harness,
pulling them into the water underneath
it and he's this guy behind him is
watching this and he's seen the blood in
the water and all The bubbles in this
big myth,
this hundred million year old behemoTh.
It's clamped
down on this guy's flash and it's
tearing it apart right in front of you
cgm.
That's what makes you so much more a
remand to me.
Like stuff like the,
the.
You would even entertain the thought of
going there.
Like,
you know,
I want to see it.
I want to see it before I want to see
it.
Just like from here.
I used to think that too.
I used to think that too,
but lately I've wanted to see it.
Man,
you know,
with all this talk of like they're
killing rhinos and killing elephants and
there was this thing today where they
are having a gun down these lions and
dim bob way because they're not
nonliving come there anymore.
Like they don't have anybody to manage
the population and these lions are
devastating there undulates,
although the antelopes and all that
shit.
So there are these,
these hunters are,
um,
they're hiring these,
what they in africa,
they call them professional hunters.
They're like guides and he's just people
that are hired by the government and
they're going in there and they had to
kill some lions,
had killed lions that were encroaching
on people's property and killing
livestock and threatening people.
IT's just so weird.
I remember that discussion you had with
jenn that night in the bar.
Yeah.
Killing deer and hill,
you'd have to kill some where they'd all
be dead.
Well,
we talked about it here on the podcast
yesterday.
I,
John Dudley was here and we found a
statistic that's unbelievably insane.
And that statistic is,
there's one point $5 million car
accidents a year where people hit deer
in America.
Uh,
just in America we knew that it was
50,000 in Michigan where like how crazy
is that?
But then we found out about the whole
country.
We were lIke,
holy shit,
that's amazing.
And when my friend john lives like him
and his wife,
when they have conversations on the
phone,
it's always like,
as they're talking about their drive
home from work,
it's always,
yeah,
we almost hit a deer.
I saw a deer.
We saw five deer.
So I drive slow.
And what's the who you can they also
have these little whistles that you put
on the front of your car that lets the
deer?
No,
your comment and the deer were generally
get out of the way.
It's like a high pissed pitched whistle
that only like the deer can here.
And then also a lot of guys they say,
well I'm just going to get a battering
ram and the front of my truck.
So what they do is they get these deer
guards and they put them on semis in
particular because there's places where
truckers are hauling goods in the middle
of the night.
Even the day doesn't even have to be in
the middle of the night,
but they'll run into a truck and that
truck will get crippled by a deer.
The deer will go into the gearing into
the engine bay and just destroy
everything,
tear out the radiator,
so they had to develop these gigantic,
like mad max style bumpers that they put
on the front of these semis just to
protect the truck itself from fucking
killing things like deer slamming into
it and a lot of people get killed to 200
a year.
We'Ll look at this.
Look at this.
We have this fucking picture.
We're looking at this picture of,
this guy's got this gigantic metal
barrier in the front of his truck and
his deer just went into it,
crushed it,
and it spray painted the side of the
truck red all the way up to the
windshield and the deer psych hanging
from the front bumper.
Fuck man.
I look at those things that they may
look at that one,
that you're hovering over it.
Click on it.
Look at the size of that thing.
I mean,
it's like you're driving around a non
aerodynamic battering ram Just to
protect your car from slamming into
animals.
Look at that.
That's crazy.
Wow.
They Do unbelievable damage when you're
hitting a hundred 50 pound animal and
you're going 70 miles an hour.
Like,
look at that one with the cars.
Get the deer hanging out of the front
like it's inside the engine.
Geez.
Yeah.
They just.
And that's if you're lucky,
if you're unlucky that go inside your
front windshield.
My friend cam,
he lives up in Oregon and a guy in front
of them,
not in front of him,
but this guy died because the man in
front of him hit a deer.
The deer went flying over that person's
hood and through his windshield and kill
them.
Oh shit.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Just fucking blood and gore.
Alright.
Jamie bumming me out,
man.
It's a deer in the front seat.
There's a lot of them.
She's,
you know,
she's a loving person,
that's why she has this distorted
perception of it.
She's a loving,
loving,
forgetting.
She says one of these animals to die.
I get it.
Nobody wants him to die.
That's the thing about this world that
we live in.
It's very ambiguous and a lot of ways.
There's a lot of.
There's not a clear right and a wrong.
There's a lot of things that seem like
they're wrong,
but if you don't do them,
everything's going to be way worse,
and one of those things is killing
beautiful animals.
It seems like it's wrong to kill deer.
If you don't kill deer,
it's way world.
They're fucked and then we're fucked and
there's going to be diseases and there's
going to be a lot of problems is also
going to be a lot of predators.
If you have a surplus of deer nature
finds a balance.
If you have a surplus of deer and
there's any predators in the area,
you're going to get a surplus of those
predators because it was predator is
going to have way more food.
They're going to thrive.
They're going to breed,
so they ain't going to have to figure
out how to manage not Just the deer,
but you're also going to have to manage
the predator population,
so you're just going to have to.
And if you don't,
you don't do it.
You've got real problems.
Yeah.
That's an 18 foot long alligator.
They shot what?
Killing cattle.
You know what?
This was in Florida,
what he was killing cows.
Jesus christ.
Look at that thing.
So this is predator control and we don't
have that much of a problem with this
kind of predator control because it's a
fucking heartless,
cold blooded monster by the way.
We were trying.
We still retarded.
We're trying to figure out what the
difference between a.
How can a komodo dragon to be the
biggest lizard and a crocodiles.
Not because it's bigger.
Crocodiles,
a reptile.
That's how stupid we are is different.
It's different because lizards,
there's reptiles,
google it.
Some people are tweeting me,
man.
That's the extent I researched it.
Yeah.
Reptiles,
bro.
Get together.
Bitch lizards are widespread group of
squats.
Guamate reptiles.
But a crocodiles,
not a lizard is a reptile to different
kinds of.
Yes,
exactly right.
Sort of like we're apes,
but we're not monkeys or apes.
No.
All monkeys or apes.
But not all.
All apes or monkeys?
Yeah.
All monkeys or apes.
But not all apes or monkeys that,
right?
No,
all apes or monkeys,
but not all monkeys or apes.
I think that's it.
Some of them are simeon's.
Like an ape
is different.
Right.
Apes or chimps and gorillas and
orangutans and us.
Right.
And baboons,
ms dot babylonian.
All mammals.
But we're not all the same kind of
mammal.
Exactly.
Fish or are like seeing marsupial's,
which is a whole different world.
The ubc and the people,
it's a pouch is hardier.
Like there was an article recently that
this guy wrote the saying that the word
monkey isn't like people criticized the
word monkey.
This is not the correct word to use.
And he said that's not true.
Not only is it not true,
all,
all apes or monkeys,
but not all monkeys or apes.
That was,
I think the title of this guy's paper
was really interesting because I always
thought that the word monkey was like
almost like a slang.
Apparently.
It's not.
Know the difference.
Can actually use that word.
Yeah.
There's just a different species of
monkeys
in your.
You're a monkey.
I about that.
Hey,
fuck you joe.
You bullshit.
Need this.
I really dove in head first class.
Abc paid for it.
I'll get you to cookie rich.
We're talking about our pals.
She,
steve sherpa was podcast started who was
in the sopranos and he's gonna be.
He's awesome.
He's going to be in the podcast.
I'm within like two weeks.
It will listen up to kill.
He's funny when he's trying to be funny.
He's funnier when he's serious.
He was bobby on the soprano's,
the big guy.
Bobby,
right?
That was his character and his problems.
I think so,
yeah.
He was married to a lead sister.
Yes.
Tony soprano.
Yeah.
She go again to fini.
The fini comes up to me.
I was with steve at the hard rock
because I think he had the wrong guy.
He goes,
he kisses me,
kisses me on the cheek,
kiss me on the cheek.
He said,
man,
I saw you on broadway.
I fucking loved you thinking,
what the fuck,
bro would I ever do?
Were you on broadway ever Just hanging
out?
Well,
I mean
cruising for.
I looked.
I saw the clothes.
I think unless I was at caroline's,
I liked the cut of your jib.
Was Caroline's on broadway,
but I mean probably where he saw you.
People don't usually call that broadway
the nun comic group.
They don't know the lender it.
They all know the verbiage.
They don't.
They don't know of vernacular.
Dominic,
do you go into New York at all?
You do theaters?
Yeah.
Next time I go,
I want to do a club though.
I think I love the beacon theater.
I had a great time the last time.
I love governors.
Governors is great openers in the
brokerage and.
But I want to do a gotham.
I haven't done gotham and forever.
Yeah,
I did a tv show there last year,
but I haven't done stand up.
Different motherfucker.
Great club.
I heard the stands great to now.
I didn't know that one.
Yeah,
I heard it's great,
but my problem is always going there for
ufc and comedy.
Like I don't have enough time to hang
around.
That's a good problem.
It's not a bad problem,
but don't have enough time to hang
around.
You know,
it's,
it's uh,
there's an interesting scene in New
York,
you know,
there's a bunch of different factions of
the scene.
There's even a weird scene in brooklyn,
you know,
so they had to out a lot of weirdness
but interesting.
It's like there's a lot of bubbling
creativity and people trying to find
their niche right now.
There's all these different people kind
of scrambling to find their niche in the
world of comedy and when you look at the
different communities that develop in
different parts of the country,
it's interesting to see the different
styles.
You know,
the people as the young comics sq.
Like how you made it.
No,
it's good.
I always get to it.
So open ended,
but I always get asked how do you get
certain things,
you know,
like the thing I've gotten,
I've lost my patience with some.
Some people like looking for an easy way
out,
you know,
you get it because people ask for you to
go.
Yeah.
Like they,
they always think like this club owner
hates them or this shit.
I said,
know,
fuck it.
Hey,
he's trying to pay his bills.
I don't even think of a.
Well,
there's some,
there's some legitimate questions that
young comics was like,
how does one go about getting a manager
to get an agent?
All that kind of stuff.
That's good.
And it's good for us to give advice to
young comics saying,
do not get a manager because it's the
first manager that asks you because
there's a lot of people that are going
to be the first manager that asks you to
manage them and they might not be right
for you.
That's why you look at a lot of guys
like chapelle or you know,
a lot of these guys that have left their
management,
like they started with one guy and they
didn't want to be with them anymore and
they laughed and they left.
Like maybe again,
maybe again,
you know,
I know quite a few guys that chapels,
old manager we saw last week at the
improv.
Yes,
yes.
Funny.
Yeah,
there's a few.
There's a few of those.
Um,
it was fucking hilarious moment.
Attention because he would touch,
you and I were standing there and he
Just said hi to me dipped in.
Well,
he knows we don't like them.
yeah,
well not that I hate them.
Just really,
there's only so much hollywood a man
could take before you just screaming out
in agony for what you have imposed upon
us.
Stop.
There's a few of those guys.
It was a funny fucking moment frozen in
time and I'll never forget the look was
dipping in.
Bought a bunch of those guys,
man,
that really shouldn't be involved in
management.
You know,
I had a um,
okay.
Kevin james,
kevin,
james,
a good friend and one of his earlier
managers was giving him fucking terrible
advice,
including wanting them to stay fat.
Kevin was trying to be healthy.
It was trying to Lose some weight and
the guy literally said to them,
cover them,
if you lose weight,
you're gonna lose roles.
You're not going to get cast lovable fat
guy that's paying off.
Stick with it,
stick with it.
But that was his real statement.
if you lose weight,
you lose roles.
and kevin came back to talk to me about
it and he was just really eaten up by
it.
It was like,
what the fuck?
Because that's not what kevin wanted to
hear.
Like kevin is a guy that works hard and
he's very smart,
but he like,
if you tell him that the sky is falling,
he'll be like,
holy shit.
Is it showing the sky's falling?
The sky's falling.
Like he needs encouragement.
Like when he's.
He's really funny.
When he's around his friends,
like we were talking about Joey being
surrounded by people like
kevin operates kind of in the same way.
I agree with what.
We had a great dinner when I remember I
came to see what the poem.
Yeah.
It was fun to see him relaxed and was,
well he knows I love him,
you know?
I mean that's why it was fun doing those
movies with him.
But kevin,
when you're supporting them and when,
when he's around people that support
them,
like he can be himself and he can cut
louis.
when you got someone telling you,
hey man,
don't get healthy because if you get
healthy you won't be successful.
You have to choose one or the other.
and I go to.
That's crazy.
think about how many people that are
funny that aren't fat telling me that
it's impossible for you to be.
You're hilarious.
His whole,
his whole,
the act wasn't predicated on,
not at all,
but he felt in some weird way that
people loved him because he was a big
jolly guy,
you know,
he's fucking talented as hell and so it
angered me.
It angered me that someone would try to
limit him in that way,
that someone would try to put him in.
But that's the problem with having a bad
manager when you're a young guy,
when everything is just starting out and
you know you're in your twenties and
you're all vulnerable and you only
started out just a few years ago and
they're still getting your feet wet and
trying to figure out how to do this
thing.
Know it's about juggling like this.
Should I go like that and you know,
kevin would do this thing where he calls
going full shimmy and full.
Shelia was any fucking freaked out about
something because shimmy was his
nickname.
We always call him shimmy.
Yeah.
And a full shimmy would be when he would
just go ballistic and like he would,
he would be like,
one time we were,
we were hanging out together and I went
with him,
he had a gig and I just went with him to
watch,
just to laugh,
just to sit down and laugh.
And because I was there,
he was like having a great time because
he knew he'd hear me laugh showing off
for you.
He said he got into it because he's,
he,
I swear to god.
people don't know how good Kevin James
was at one,
at one point in his career.
I mean I'm assuming he's just as good
now,
but I haven't seen him do standup in a
long time.
But when he would,
he was going off and,
and he,
he,
he like was faces red.
It was spitting and it was just going
off about something.
And that was what we would call going
full shimmy and like be,
you know,
you're not going to do that if you're
worried about people not liking you.
If you lose,
you've got to be free to go off.
You know?
It's like we're a guy like joey,
he's got,
you got to be free to be able to just
cut loose and those bad managers are
fucking terrible for that because
they've never done stand up.
They don't know what it takes.
They don't,
they don't,
they haven't grasped the concept that
each individual has to find their own
path.
All they're thinking about it as how to
mold someone into some bullshit persona
from marketing for a marketing point of
view.
Know for marketing purposes.
That's what they're thinking.
How can I sell this guy?
I think the,
the,
the pith thing is really,
really well.
What I'd like to say,
just take your own path.
Some people make it in two years.
SOme people making 10,
15 like look,
look like we're talking about joey.
D is like a.
Once you rip a story to tell you about,
uh,
your name and your manager on the to
mind,
he probably,
I don't know if he wants that.
Okay.
So it was easy to find,
but it was him and he said he had.
We alwaYs have stories.
So he says,
I tell trip.
I said,
we're going to lake mead on saturday.
You want to go?
And steve goes,
no,
I can't put a.
I can comp you a boat,
and he got your manager says to me,
who the fuck else can copy a boat?
But europe,
he was so connected to vegas.
Syrup is the best.
Such a character as is my manager.
He just cut him character till he always
really into now he goes striper fishing.
Really surf casting loves it.
It's understanding the water.
Yeah.
He could stay on the water with waiters.
He could just stand on the.
On the beach itself and cast into the
water.
The ocean.
Yeah.
We catches these giant ass fucking
striped bass.
God,
there's A wild world just outside New
York and a lot of people don't know
about it.
LikE you go to certain parts of long
island.
He goes,
oh my god,
it's.
But it's incredible.
He took me once.
We weren't successful,
but I got it.
Just being there with them,
I got what he likes about it.
Like there's a whole process to it.
You take some air out of your tires and
there's places where you're allowed to
drive onto the sand and you pull up on a
sand.
These are like fairly remote areas in
long island and these guys cotu
specifically just for surf casting,
striped bass.
That's what everybody wants to catch.
They want to catch stripers and casting
out these giant ass fucking polls
because you know you can get a 30 pound
fat.
She got big ass striped bass out there
and they don't.
You don't catch them that often,
but sometimes you run into a whole
school level them and everybody catches
him and those are like these magical
times.
It'S an interesting.
It's a lot of ways.
FisHing is like an interesting
discipline and jeff,
I don't have the patience for it now to
add.
Will you play pool though?
I love pool.
But you have patients for that?
Yeah.
Well I guess I have pages for the things
I love fishing to me.
I can't imagine.
Have you ever caught a fish and then
cooked it and ate it?
No.
How dare you?
Who are you?
How'd you get in here?
I'm a pescatarian.
It's one of these people that say
they only meet,
but they fish like as if that's humane
is a fish,
don't have feelings.
Well,
they don't take care of the children.
What fish?
You know this shit out.
Some eggs and the mail comes over and
comes on him like a freak show.
That's what happens.
That's very rude.
That's how they do it.
Who we talk about this later.
I saw a guy on instagram bragging about
how he's 90 percent vegetarian.
He was talking shit about people who eat
meat and hunters in particular.
You're talking shit about hunting and
he's saying,
look,
I get it.
I'm 90 percent vegetarian,
but you know what you people are doing.
It's awful like fuck bacon because it's
delicious.
How funny is that?
We're someone who can attest that he
fucking bacon ham sandwiches
cheeseburgers.
Every now and then he goes off,
so he's tryIng to say that he's got some
moral right to complain about someone
who hunts because he's 90 percent
vegetarian and vegan either by the way,
which means milk,
animal products,
eggs.
That's a tough particulate fuck.
Ridiculous dummy,
but that that taking the moral high
ground from saying I killed less animals
per year than most men most of the time,
not killing anything.
People are so goofy.
Ninety percent vegetarian.
The fact that you would write that down
and go,
yes,
and that's it posted.
I'm.
Will I let this motherfucker?
No,
I've never heard that.
That'S the most ridiculous.
I've ever heard a lot of
rationalizations,
but that's so many dummies out there,
if you will.
I think that like if you did go catch a
fish once and then cook it and eat it,
you would get it.
You definitely get a little bit.
It's fun.
It's fun to catch them and then they
taste so good.
If you can catch a fish and then have it
cooked or you cook it within a few hours
of pulling it out of the ocean.
Holy shit.
It's like a different thing.
Something happens to fish when it sits
around for too long.
Even when it's frozen and thawed out,
it just doesn't retain the same quality
that it has when you pull it right out
of the water.
Yeah,
that's pretty cool.
I was at honolulu and they had a,
a place where you cook your own fish.
I didn't want to cook.
We'll fish
to wash my own dishes to what the book
had a restaurant.
We don't like go to those,
uh,
those grill places where you lay the
meat out.
They have like a japanese place near me.
Then I was like these little grills in
front of the bace yeah,
something like that.
And you lay the meaning,
you cook it right in front of you.
You seen that show?
Korean barbecue.
But I've also seen a japanese one,
you know,
they probably ripped it off froM the
kranz.
Let's be honest.
It's still a controversy over the year.
Cook.
You cook it yourself.
It's kinD of weird.
You're cooking,
you know,
what do you,
do you provide Me a plate of meat?
It was a couple of actual like grill.
I don't,
I don't know exactly where they are,
but I've seen them on tv probably
because there's only one or two.
But uh,
You go pick up your meat like a butcher,
like the front of the store is at
butcher type place in the back is a
bunch of grills and you hang out with
your friends and grill your own steaks.
Wow.
At the restaurant.
Then just sit down like a picnic table.
Do the.
I know if you know what you're doing
though,
it's fun.
And then you don't have to do any of the
cleanup if they do it the right way.
Like if they have really good grills
they use like mesquite lump charcoal and
got,
you know,
they set the calls up.
Nice.
I have a pretty cool.
I use white to cook and yummy.
Which why cook cook cook is like a thing
a friend of mine owns it and it's like
high end restaurants that deliver.
It's just called a friend of mine.
He uh,
he's a triathlete.
Right.
And he's probably gonna make the
olympics.
He was standing over my house and I
said,
you want to go shopping or something?
I go and I hand them the Yummy thing.
What do you mean?
I said,
we're not going anywhere.
He Just fucking call for the food.
You don't go to restaurants.
Oh,
I go to restaurants.
Yeah.
But you'd rather just have it delivered?
No,
just from watching a game or something.
Oh,
okay.
So do you cook ever?
Never reheat.
So you have like a whole great.
Just sits there.
I this the only time that my stove is
used as the heat.
A border for t.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
You've never like sat down and cooked a
steak and mashed potatoes or anything?
I used to cook what I call chicken.
I rarer,
which was a two lonG,
two lumps of margarine and black pepper
on chicken.
A 325 for an hour.
Jesus,
the only thing I ever cooked.
How bad was it?
I don't know.
I was starving.
Started facebook.
Pretty good.
This is when I was really broke through
on my little joey bag of donuts attacked
you.
So you never got into like cooking
yourself a meal.
That's interesting.
I'm a big fan of cooking.
Yeah,
I love it.
It's good.
I keep your head straight.
I'm walt's also bomb.
It's a satisfying.
We make a nIce meal and sit down and eat
it.
I like it.
Plus I like controlling what goes in my
body.
One hundred percent know,
like I'm on this wacky,
very low carb,
low sugar intake diet,
no process or no added sugar.
I don't eat any candy or soda,
no ice cream,
no bullshit.
And on this diet I kind of have to make
sure that I control like even salad
dressings,
like you would think you'd go to a nice
restaurant and you order a salad and
then you're eating it.
You go,
okay,
this is filled with sugar.
I could taste this.
Dressings,
films,
sugar.
Well tHey don't care.
They want it to be delicious and health.
Well they also don't have to put like
the ingredients in the menu.
Like when you see the menu and it says
like balsamic vinegarette doesn't say
what's in that balsamic vinograd.
It might be just chock full of fucking
sugar.
Some of those stakes or ruth's chris or
one of those.
I don't want to nail any,
any particular steakhouse,
but they,
they broil them in butter.
Like,
it ain't fucking fat enough to eat a
steak in butter.
It's all good for you though.
Well,
it's delicious.
I don't know.
Good for you.
Good for you though.
For your fucking heart problems.
Hey,
you got a problem already?
Set the stakes.
Paul.
You've converted me.
It's not dietary cholesterol.
Barely moved the needle on blood lipids.
There's all sorts of problems that lead
to people having high cholesterol,
sedentary lifestyle.
um,
there's a lot of genetic problems,
but they're finding now that like
saturated fats and all these things that
we're blaming and on issues with people.
That's not necessarily what the problem.
What's the problem?
There's a host of problems that exercise
is a big problem.
It's a big problem.
Huge problem with people.
The over consumption of certain types of
foods,
you know,
sedentary lifestyles.
You Just even sitting in a chair all
day.
It's fucking terrible.
I get inspired today because of the bed
I was playing pool and I'm going to get
back on the table.
You're going to get back.
I just say a challenge.
So we have a table in your apartment?
yeah.
What the fuck?
Dumb.
I mean how lazy you have to be not to
walk and I mean I got a treadmill.
I got a bike,
I did tHe treadmill today for 20
minutes.
Like it's a big deal,
but it's better than nothing sitting
there like a big
fucking blow.
Big tits.
The treadmills.
Great for 20 minutes.
That's good.
If you could do 20 minutes every day,
just force yourself to do only 20
minutes every day.
Put a television show on.
It's what I do.
That's great.
Watch cnn or espn,
you know,
it's great.
Do you ever see steve?
Steve harvey does his morning show.
Steve harvey does the fucking morning
shoW sometimes on an elliptical machine.
Really?
It's taking phone calls on a goddamned
elliptical machine.
This is a radio show,
steve harvey in the morning.
So hilarious grind and hustle and grind
and hustle.
That's what he says.
He works a lot with your head down.
Granted,
hustle.
Yeah,
he works a lot,
man.
It does pay.
The guy works hard.
You can't say anything other than that.
When you.
You're talking about the guy's worth
work ethic.
Steven was constantly doing so.
I don't know many people.
Your energy.
I'm doing a bunch of fun and I'm
enjoying things.
Enjoyable.
Things anoint that sounded like it was a
14 slip,
but it's not.
They're all enjoyable.
You know,
podcasts are enjoyable.
Ufc is enjoyable.
This is enjoyable.
It's fun to watch you to understand that
now because a,
you're.
You really have fun now.
You know that like the difference
between you when I first met you with
all of us,
hopefully evolve and hopefully for the
better,
but I see you.
You have that smirk on your face.
That is.
I know that you're enjoying it.
It's fun.
You know?
You know,
it's fun.
I've been,
I've been enjoying being at the store.
That's a big part of it.
I've been enjoying that and it's funny
how your friends can inspire.
like jim carrey was in when I.
I don't know if I told you this.
ended up getting like a little part in
his pilot lands.
comedian.
Yeah.
On what is that thing going to show?
There was a lot of hype.
I don't think it's going to show up for
a while.
I think the cast,
and it's still a short starts shooting
till julY.
oh,
they haven't started shooting yet,
but in this one little kid,
the little kid that you always comes out
like when you.
When I saw you in marin in the back,
I really wanted to have a good set for
the fun of showing up front of my friend
jim was there.
I hadn't seen him since actually since
rodney died and jim,
I knew him from the comedy store and I
went.
I sHowed off for him like I wanted to
do,
you know what I mean?
I'm not above admitting that I was
fucking showing what's inspiring.
I mean you can call it,
show it off,
but you know,
you want to put on a show for him.
Yeah.
Something wrong with that.
That's one of the cool things about that
place.
This is a very high level.
You know,
man,
go there any night.
You're gonna.
See sebastian,
you see burgers,
you.
So you know tom cigars in there now you
know his,
his wife has got damn hilarious to jesus
christ.
She's good.
Christina,
hiS wife.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
I was there.
We're watching her that.
No,
that's what I went on.
Went on right after.
You're making fun of that pit.
How funny is she?
She's a monster man.
She's fucking podcasts.
Hilarious to you heard their podcast.
It's called your mom's house.
It's really funny,
man.
They're,
they're really silly.
They're really fun together.
It's a great.
And they do want a
real smart too.
I was talking to them aBout it,
you know,
we're talking about like how many they
do a week and he's like,
we'd like to do one a week because that
way we do like a lot of living in
between shows,
you know,
and it's paying off.
They do live shows.
They do live podcasts on the road.
That didn't even work with you
sometimes.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I met tom when we were doing the maximum
real men of comedy tour.
Me,
charlie murphy and john heffron.
And what we did was we went across the
country and they would use a local act
to warm the show up.
That would be like the first guy.
So the first guy would do like,
I don't know,
10 or 15 or something like that and that
would be the local guy and in some
places they didn't use local guys.
They just used guys that somebody liked
or somebody thought was good.
they just cast somebody,
you know,
I don't remember who the booking agent
was that put the tour together,
but they did this and they were,
you know,
some good guys.
So funny guys.
And tHen there was cigar and we were in
phoenix.
We did that theater in the round of
hollywood theater and a cigar went out.
It just killed and I was crying,
laughing and he's just ridiculous.
And,
and,
and his jokes are absurd.
Just,
he's so good.
He was so good at then.
And then,
you know,
we became friends and I started taking
them the road.
Is there anybody at anytime in your
career that you didn't want to follow?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
When I was young for sure because I
didn't understand.
I would think that them doing well meant
that I wouldn't do well.
But all that means is that you need to
get better.
You need to work on your act.
You know this,
this.
Everyone's wants to protect the state
that they're in right now.
like anytime you're,
if you're in a state that the audience
doesn't think is funny,
you got to figure out a way out of that.
Either got to figure out a way out of
that with more material or you gotta
there's Gotta be a way and you might not
find that way tonight,
but that's a lesson and you've got to
take that lesson and you got to figure
out how,
what went wrong.
Well,
one of the things that goes wrong,
a lot of times you see someone kill anD
you get nervous and like,
shit,
I got to follow that.
You don't instead think this is awesome.
I'm laughing,
I'm having fun.
THe audience is having fun too.
Isn't comedy great?
You know,
that's why I take joey in the road with
me like I'm doing like the arlington
theater was tony hinchcliffe crushed for
like 25 minutes and then joey crushed
for like 20 minutes,
25 minutes or whatever.
He did many minutes.
Still still going.
Well you can't.
Do you know,
you've always been great dom,
you know,
when we first met and I was young and we
were in montreal together and then we
met at amsterdam and plates and pulled
down the you,
you were always from the time I was like
basically just kind of starting out.
You've always been like encouraging and
cool and fun to hang out with and you've
always been like a real comic's comic
and there's not a lot of guys
unfortunately that maintain that of um,
camaraderie and friendship with the
other people involved in their
profession,
you know?
Well,
I appreciate you saying that.
I mean I get it back though,
you know,
it's like intelligent krista leo saiD
one night he goes,
you know,
it's interesting about you.
He goes,
I never think of you as older than us.
I think it was one of us.
That's all I want.
I just want to be judged on my
performance.
Not that I'm older.
Well,
You never stopped growing either.
You never stop working and you never
stopped growing and you never stopped
constantly in evolving your act and you
Just have sharpie as you've always been.
if not sharper and because of that,
like you're always going to be low.
One of us for us,
all of us.
I think even for you and I in the early
days,
there was those guys that came around
that the puzzle was too difficult for
them to solve for whatever reason,
and they never got there.
They never got there and then they were
stuck and they would do these sets of
the store and they would do the same
material and you knew the jokes.
You knew the punchline because they had
been doing them for 15 years and we all
knew those guys.
Those guys.
Well,
it's unfortunate,
but.
But those are the old guys.
It's not being old.
That chronological.
It's more of a state.
Yeah.
Well it's just they're stagnant.
THey're stagnant.
Whereas a guy like carlin to the very
end was writing new material.
This guy,
he died in a hotel.
He was to the very end was writing and
creating and putting out a new hour
every year.
Just kept doing it.
Yeah,
I mean it doesn't happen and respected
to the end.
Right.
Absolutely.
Revered to the end.
People would go see him,
loving it to the end.
Well,
you know,
who was amazing in that regard was
rodney dangerfield because he did joke
jokes that we would really consider
corny.
His fucking character was so
overwhelmingly hilarious,
brilliant that we all loved him.
We all left and we respected him and he
never stopped writing.
No,
no.
Rodney also was another supporter of
comedians like rodney dangerfield
specials.
The young comedian specials that you
were on a dice was on.
Hicks was on that.
Kinison was on shema.
Shema.
Lenny clarke let it.
Clark.
Carol liefer.
Barry sobel.
Yup.
The.
He.
He let the world know about some of the
best talent of your era.
Did I ever tell you about when the
audition for him now was at the comedy
store was supposed to 10 minutes each.
Right.
So barry sobel goes on to this 25
minutes.
Then damon goes on this 25 minutes and
I'm fucking furious.
Right?
So I go up and all I do is I said what
the daemon expect and I love damon,
but this is not.
Again,
this is a long time ago.
I go with daymond expected,
like get funny at the 23rd minute,
you know,
like it was like all of a sudden these
bomb and I said,
it wasn't happening for you tonight.
Daymond let it go.
And I Just felt so rodney comes up to
me,
he goes,
you don't kill your funny,
but what you do is lay into people.
WHat the fuck you got an act of war,
you know?
And so then he saw me at the improv and
then I got it,
but it was,
that was my introduction
to rodney dangerfield.
What was like.
Did you get upset at damon and not upset
at barry's?
So no,
I was upset about both of them.
Just a daymond happened to be the one
right on before me was well farm or
something.
He was now they were really tanking and
both of them are very effective
comedians and I was just pissed up
because my thing is,
you know,
it's 10 minute addition,
just do it,
do the best you can and get off,
but don't keep going because you're not
doing well or don't keep going because
you're doing well.
Yeah.
There's some people that like if you are
the audition for the comedy store and
they give you one of those five minutes
bots or three minutes or whatever the
hell it is.
How many minutes is it?
I think it's three and when they come
see you though,
bring somebody in special showcase.
This seems like 10 minutes each,
but I think if you bring somebody in,
if someone auditions for the talent
coordinator was how many minutes do they
do?
I don't like a pro comes in and they do
a set.
They do 10 minutes.
I'm not sure,
but whatever it is,
if you go over that,
they just want to ask you.
Oh,
I know this won't.
I mean we don't need this.
Yeah.
We don't need some person who can't find
a friend that.
Yeah,
unfortunately.
Yeah.
I just respect other people's time and
let you know.
Like I told fucking thing about going on
when eddie griffin and those guys and
never had a problem with eddie,
but that's,
you know that he will go on for hours.
It would close the place.
We'd go on at nine and stay on 1:00 in
the morning
and he wasn't even supposed to be like
on the lineup.
He would just show up,
but that was when he was a huge star.
You know,
that place has always been weird with
when people are huge stars.
They could just come in like damon needs
to be able to come in anytime he wanted
and he would go on stage and do 45
minutes or whatever he wanted.
You know,
it's like you,
you allowed tHem,
you know,
you're allowed them that moment with
some people.
I mean,
my thing is like one of the things that
I had anything to anybody younger than
me that was my friend was to,
and it was not to abuse your power or be
a jerk off about it.
If somebody,
if you're going to bump somebody,
go up to them and say,
hi,
I'm going to do 10 minutes.
Are you cool with that?
If they say,
I can't,
please don't wait.
You know,
a lot of us have a real problem with it.
We don't like it and we don't do it and
we haven't done it,
you know,
I'm not a big believer in it.
I think it's not that hard to call.
You never bumped people.
No,
I don't think it's hard to call.
It's not hard to call in and get on a
schedule and just,
you know,
try to figure it out.
And if you do show up and they asked to
put you on,
I don't think that's bumping.
Like if you show up in the club,
asks you to go on and do a study.
Eddie shore's okay.
You know,
you don't say hey I want to go on after
I rare I'll put me up.
Because that's the thing that like,
you know,
who used to like to do,
like I don't want to,
not really mexican.
He used to like to show up.
Have you heard of it?
Don't say his name is like candy man.
But people like to do it as like a power
trip.
Exactly.
And they like to do it in front of you.
Let's say if they didn't like you,
they will go up in front of you.
I'm going to go on after.
I really like say if someone was going
after you and he didn't like them,
he'd go on right after you say I'm going
on next and then just go in there and
just crush for 40 minutes and do half
your shit.
But that was a different scenario,
you know,
it was like a vampire and an artist's
colony.
Red band said that he saw somebody do
one of my jokes.
Who,
I dunno,
I think he said then the guy they were.
It was like on a tv thing and the guy
hollered out that maria is joke,
joke.
I don't know.
He because he told me he was going to
text you with that.
I guess he forgot.
That's unlikely,
but I saw a thing.
Killing prime forgets everything.
Oh,
does he?
It's partying.
Seventh grade time.
Kids squeezing an Orange.
he's getting the juices out.
yeah.
He smoked A little weed.
Dom.
He does.
Does he does anything?
All things in moderation.
Joseph.
So your xanax thing,
it puts you.
You were saying at the beginning of the
podcast puts you like in a like a level
state.
Is there any downside to it?
Yeah.
Drowsiness,
drowsiness,
but the drowsiness probably calms you
down.
It makes you like maybe a little bit
more hilarious.
Yeah.
I don't mean I don't get nervous for the
stage.
I don't get nervous.
I get nervous for just being the ent
existential angst of being or like were
you worried about mortality?
Worry about death or just on the hip on
it?
You know,
I mean I was,
I was a stupid joke about we have to
have a finite number of loads left
that we have enough just to shoot a
little.
And I was thinking it's kind of sad but
interesting.
I wonder how many loads I have left.
Well,
it's a matter of how much your body
needs.
I would imagine if you spit in a bucket,
your body would be forced to produce
more spit because you're constantly
spitting.
Yeah.
You know,
like if you decided,
okay,
today is april,
whatever the fuck it is,
team 2016,
the next 30 years.
I'm trying to see how much spit I can do
in my spare time so I'm to get a vat,
I'm going to dig a hole in my backyard
and have some glass makers make this
gigantic vat on my lift up the lid and
I'm going to spit in it every day and
I'm going to try to fill that glass up
before I die here.
Imagine
you get a good answer out of you.
If you did that,
if you had to Like the thing like you
know like the lid of a fucking hot tub
and you lift it up and there's only got
seven foot deep that it's made out of
glass and you're Just chucking louise in
there and closing it up every day.
How much spit would you actually be able
to create?
Prevent evaporation,
so you would probably create life.
You can probably some new fucking
organism that grow out a thing and kill
your fucking neighbors.
Joe,
who cleans up a bit with spit that,
so I appreciate that.
A little classier level spit.
Well,
I would sAy calm.
You could do it with two,
but you wouldn't be able to measure it
because hopefully you're coming into
somebody
or in the back of her head
that's hard to scrape
it off and wait.
Exactly.
But if you spit into a vat,
you'd have like a control.
Have the that you have a nice seal air
tight seal so it's not going to
evaporate.
You know what I'm saying?
Lift it up.
Close it down.
I'm getting hungry.
Yeah.
I mean hoW much come would be lost in
their hair alone?
You would never get an accurate
measurement.
You would have to like adjust for hair
like.
Okay.
How much did you end up scraping off?
My got about a half an ounce,
but I think there's another quarter in
that hair.
Okay.
You'd have to like put an asterisk next
to how much come did he come today.
So I definitely have the thing of how
many times left in life.
Even when I was a kid,
I rememBer being four years old and look
in the mirror and going,
I can't believe I'm going to die some
day and I'm so fucking cute.
I remember a conversation to have with
my stepdad when I was seven and it was
right when I had lost my religion.
I lost my religion one.
Oh,
seven,
seven.
Wow.
I went to see age of reason.
Catholic school,
catholic school did me in.
I just realized it was bullshit and my
parents were kinda.
My stepdad was a hippie and my,
my parents were kind of becoming hippies
and my mom was becoming a hippie,
you know,
hanging out my step dad.
But when I asked him,
I said,
well,
if you know,
if there's no heaven,
there's no god,
what happens to you when you die?
And He's like,
probably nothing.
Probably just use aren't here anymore.
I started crying.
Sure.
I remember I was just so scared.
I was just a natural instinct.
You don't want to end.
Yeah.
We all have it and it's part of the,
the management of life is trying to
decide which way you allow your brain to
go.
Not just today,
but forever.
For as long as you're conscious.
There's got to be certain roads.
You don't go down and if you,
if you do,
you have to be able to look at those
subjects or whatever those roads are
rationally because if you just want to
freak out and sit here and freak out
about death,
you're not going to enjoy this moment
which you have.
You are alive.
You mean you right now.
We are all everyone listening to this is
alive and that this is all you've got.
This is what you've got.
You've got right now,
so what do you mean?
When is it going to be over?
It does.
It literally does not matter for this
moment right now,
for this moment right now,
it's hard to do because got enjoy this
and it's going to go away one day,
but you don't have to dwell on that.
Just leave that knowledge in your head
and enjoy this [inaudible].
What a shame it would be if this whole
thing was temporary and the whole time
you could enjoy it because you were
worried.
When was it going to end and there were
so many cool aspects of it and so many
fun things to do.
Weird things to see and cool people to
meet and fun food to try and books to
read and movies to watch and places to
visit and he just
didn't do it.
He didn't do it because you are
paralyzed by the fear of this thing that
you're not even experiencing to the
fullest ending and also by the seeking
and the reward at the end.
Like as if this time isn't a reward in
itself,
you know,
this time,
minutes.
Yeah.
I mean that's what it takes a long
fucking time to cement that into my
stupid ed and that's why,
you know,
when you say like you see me having fun,
I am having fun.
I'm having more fun now doing standup
than I ever have in my life and I
haven't seen it.
It was fun,
man.
It's a fun thing,
you know,
it's.
When I approach it like that,
it'S been more rewarding.
I think it might act is better.
I think that's all.
It's just.
And there's so many of us now.
there's so many of us.
When you do that one bit,
you're the closer.
You were so into it.
It's so fucking funny but spooky,
but on so many levels it gets me.
That's why I asked you last night if you
had done it for a special yet.
That's going to be the next one.
That'll be on the national.
You're closer to.
I can't,
I can't follow it right now.
Um,
but I might be doing it in june.
Trying to figure out what I'm going to
do.
My special.
I'm working it all out right now.
Dom herrera herrera from now on.
Netflix one within an x ray.
I should do one over and done with
funny on the side lines.
Now you should do one man.
When was the last time you had someone
come out to see like that?
I don't remember.
When.
are you doing a headliner setting down
in town?
Yeah.
Or anywhere near where?
The comedy magic club in june.
Yeah.
I'll have the netflix people come out to
see you.
Oh yeah.
Fuck.
Cool.
Fuck it.
Do you know when in june?
I'm not positive.
I should know the date.
You should know your fucking dates.
Dumb either.
Luckily yet on the internet.
The first week I'm at a kilkenny.
The second week I'm at,
I'm
a second week,
second brad garrett.
10th and the 11th.
So you'll be in vegas.
That was in vegas and then then the next
week is a pretty sure that's it.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's either that or the weekend before
the July 4th.
Um,
I think I might be home or that might be
a ufc.
Why don't I feel like that's a ufc.
Okay.
There's your schedule a.
He had a,
a nod.
Yeah.
The July 6th through twelfth.
Las vegas.
Brad garrett.
Comedy club,
june rather six through twelfth.
And then right after that,
it must be comedy magic club sexual
comedy festival.
Yeah.
I don't know why that's the magic clubs
not in there.
And the funniness see perth,
Australia and then delray beach,
Florida.
It's a big chunk of the earth.
Yeah.
That's a big swath.
You're cutting a path through this great
land of ours.
Yes.
You are with your jokes.
Humor giving.
So what's that?
We're going to wrap this up.
Okay.
I just got to say I had so much fun last
night with the girls to store.
Oh yeah,
david,
the greatest staff,
the girls and the boys too.
It's not be gender specific.
Tinkering around with the girls and
jessie wonder.
Yeah,
she's great in the wait staff is great.
Everybody's great management staffs
crate emily's great.
The people that work there are just
great.
It's a great place,
man.
It's got a great vibe now.
It's almost a completely different
universe.
It is completely different.
It's like it was sad.
There's happiness there now.
It was like he was sick and someone came
along and gave it medicine and now it's
not sick anymore.
Now it's a flourishing.
Exactly.
Totally different.
It was on the ropes for three years
while I think it was going to stay open.
Well,
when I came back with,
I watched already do a special,
which I,
uh,
if you watch the podcast with ari and
you notice that I almost cried like a
bitch.
You'd be correct when,
when I left it or no,
I almost cried because we were talking
about me coming back to the store and
you know,
here it goes again.
Are,
he's been my friend since he was a
doorman.
Yeah.
You know,
we were buddies when he was an amateur,
I mean it was just starting out and so
for me to be on a hiatus from the store,
I was,
I wouldn't,
didn't perform there for seven years.
The one of the main,
the main motivating factor was two
things.
One that I'm adam egot.
It came,
came to see me at the improv and then
talk to me and told me he's running it
now and I knew adam from phoenix.
Phoenix,
right.
That was big.
But the biggest one was
that a.
Or he was doing his special.
They're just no way,
you know,
there's no way I was going to miss that.
Right.
Well,
do you remember me telling you to come
back?
Yeah,
because I said to you,
I remember exactly the conversation.
I said,
joe,
that past is over.
We're,
we've got a bunch of your friends are
over there and we would love you to come
back.
It was like going to because they bet on
the wrong horse.
Right.
And that whole thing went down.
It was just so many crazy things going
on at that place was running it before
it was out of his mind.
This has nothing to do with the past.
That's why it was so great that you came
back.
You know,
everybody loves you there.
Everybody we have.
So you know,
it's,
it's fun because you,
you don't separate yourself from them,
you know,
like,
like we were talking about people's
attitudes and it's just such a,
it's so fun to have you back there and
like,
I know that I'm going to see you once or
twice a week there.
You know,
before you were to places that I didn't
feel like driving to the ice house.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I hear you brother.
I feel the same way,
man.
I'm happy.
But I still like doing the ice house to
man.
Oh no,
I'm not trying weekend there soon.
I like iT too.
I fucking place is awesome.
This is the greatest time ever for
comedy.
This is the greatest spot to la.
If I didn't live in la,
I'd want to be here.
I really would like.
There's so much good comedy on.
Here's a lot of good writing going on.
It's competitive,
you know,
it's competitive and it's also
healthy supportive way more than it was
like 20 years ago.
Like when we first came here,
you were here before me,
but when I first came here in
[inaudible] 94,
it just was fucking real shitty.
Wasn't supportive.
No.
Everybody was out for themselves.
it was tainted also by,
this is what this is.
I have this theory and I'm pretty pretty
sure there's some validity to it.
I think that the standup comedy of the
eighties and the nineties that we knew
of this was also tainted by the
television business because everybody
was trying to get a tv deal.
Yeah,
so the guys who came out here,
everybody was trying to do showcase sets
for executives and for writers and they
were trying to get a set together so
they could cash in like roseanne and get
their cells that fat seinfeld money or
then rhett butler money get the long
cash that will come with being the star
of a sitcom.
That was the goal of course,
and so we.
We had this sort of actory thing going
on in comedy and it was weird,
it was weird for a long time,
but when the sitcoms started drying up
because of the reality shows,
a lot of comics got resentful because
like even marin got resentful with me
because my show in his mind was taking
up a slot that could have been filled by
comics that were working as writers,
but my point was like,
but yeah,
but the comments work and his writers
know this fear factor.
Oh,
fear effect,
but my point was at is writers are still
not even doing standup.
I guess not taking anything away from
the art of standup.
It's just a slot on television.
Ultimately,
those shows all the brutal and weird and
the way that they just sort of decimated
the sitcom landscape.
A lot of them that there's not even
nearly as many sitcoms as there used to
be.
Remember how many goddamn sitcoms there
were at one time I met with.
Yeah,
there's a lot of fucking reality shows.
A lot of weirdness in these,
but what that forced everyone to do was
to go online and then stand up right now
is just about standup again.
Yeah,
so like the goal is now not to get a
sitcom,
which is still awesome if you're like
someone like dalea,
but the goal is instead to get netflix
specials like so gura,
so garage has no tv to speak of and he's
selling out big ass theaters.
He's killing it and it's just from
netflix specials.
So the whole thing changed from his
podcast,
from other people's podcasts where you
got to know him and then from netflix
specials the whole thing changed.
So that's the goal now.
So I think like the level of comedy is
really high now because everybody's like
in the comedy again,
like there's a lot of guys that are into
doing it for the sake of doing it.
JuSt the fun of going out there and
putting on a live show.
yeah.
Somebody asked me to go,
what do you still do it so much?
I go because I love it and I'm trying to
improve.
It will improve how you're going to
improve and like basically your agent,
I don't know,
but I'm going to try to fucking give up
and go,
well,
you know,
I know I'll do this bit that I did 20
years
ago.
There'll be new to them.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well that's why,
you know,
I,
talia said you're not an older guy like
you're a comic.
And I think that,
I think that applies to everything in
life.
You know,
if you got a guy who's a,
an old car designer is resting on his
laurels or a guy who was an old author
was writing shitty books and resting on
the books that he wrote 20,
30 years ago,
he's not going to be as interesting,
you know,
there's no reason to not produce and be
creative.
There's no reason to.
He could still do it and you'll feel
better if you do.
There was a guy,
uh,
you know,
um,
I don't feel like putting them down
really well.
No,
I'm just kidding.
And is on stage and,
and chris,
that guy at fucking mother fucker.
so the guy.
Do you ever hear shame attached?
Doing a jewish joe pesci getting blown
by Joan Rivers.
That's fucking funny.
she's hilarious.
She's worked with me in reno in may.
she lives up there.
That should be up there.
Was that.
She lives in vegas.
Yeah.
How come that's on your.
Who does your calendar there?
The guy in montreal.
Kill him to get his fucking shit
together.
What else is there?
The vegas thing.
Then governors and that's all down the
road.
brokerage.
They should let people know what's the
guy's name?
Call them out.
Uh,
you shit.
Fuck.
It's me too.
And that you're not getting into him for
things.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You got an email.
Got,
you know,
the twitter thing helps a lot more.
Oh yeah.
No,
it's amazing.
Facebook's great.
Instagram is great.
You know,
I never been on facebook.
never.
Never.
I have,
I hired two girls to help me with that.
They sent dick pics to everybody.
Yeah.
Whose idea was that first idea?
Was that somebody this year?
The dick pic guy?
Uh,
no dick pics are probably like
polaroids.
They probably drew my cave walls.
Probably dudes trace the outline of
their deck and threw rocks at women
common.
We'll go look at it.
I've been ticked.
Pigs had been around as long as cameras
have been around.
How long did the camera existed before
the first dude took a picture of his
dick with it.
How long a week?
How long?
The first degree.
I bet the first dick pic was to answer
that.
I honestly believe that if cameras are.
If they don't have to be operated by
more than one person at the time they're
created,
I wouldn't give it more than a month
before a guy took a picture of his dick
from the making of the very first camera
to taking a photo of his dick.
I would say one month because otherwise,
how else you gotta look at your dick.
You have to use a mirror and those
mirrors back then were like looking into
a pond.
you barely see what you look like.
You know you'll get your reflection in a
car mirror like a car window.
It's a nice storage.
I'm getting hungry now.
Look at this.
Two thousand five year old erotic,
2,500 year old erotic graffiti.
Found an unlikely setting on the age g
and island.
Well,
what's erotic about it as a dick?
Guys got a weird dick though.
I think you should go to an ancient dr.
Throwing balls with the little squares
in his looks.
His balls with a grenade.
yeah.
Who's has it?
That's a dick.
That can be a cactus over here.
What's that?
Archeologists.
TiNa's art.
If they don't know shit that in a dick,
if that's a dick,
are dicks have evolved?
Imagine if we found out the dicks used
to look different.
They've changed.
They've changed shape like we find like
a petrified frozen dick from like a
million years ago and we.
Oh my god,
what would it look like a million years
ago we'll look for.
Has changed,
right?
Neanderthals had those giant ass fucking
foreheads to look like a.
Like a forearm was growing off the top
of your brows.
Right?
This big thing at the end of the faces
were different.
Their build were different.
What are their dicks were different that
you could actually eat with it?
Put your hands exactly.
Push food and the amount that was
watching an elephant eat bamboo ones and
the elephant.
It's kind of interesting to see like you
don't.
I don't think I realized until I saw an
elephant eat at the zoo,
how much dexterity they have in that
trunk,
but he's stepping on this bamboo and
just tearing the leaves off like really
like unbelievably powerful.
It just rips them off with no effort at
all.
Bundles it up and then he was stuffing
it in his mouth and I was watching the
whole thing play out.
I was like,
wow,
what an interesting body part.
That trunk is.
What other animal can feed itself with
his nose?
Wrap its nose around,
leaves hold branches down with its feet
and pulled.
Just strip the leaves off,
roll it up in a ball with its nose
already can do it.
No,
you can't do it anymore.
They don't try to think of an answer to
his question with me.
Oh,
about looking jewish.
What?
What is it about me that makes me look
jewish?
I love the red.
If you're talking to him about his
religious past.
No.
When he was a young boy,
he lived in Israel and he spent a lot
young management say he spent like 12
hours a day reading like ancient jewish
religious texts.
yeah.
He was a.
He was in a very religious program.
He was seriously like a dedicated jus
like to learning judaea,
judaism to learning hebrew,
like seriously dedicated.
Somewhere along the line he just woke up
and like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Funny shit man.
It's interesting.
Is it like,
you know,
they say politics makes strange
bedfellows.
Will sodas,
comedy?
Like when,
what regular world would you and him and
joey be friends.
Yeah.
We'd have to work together.
You,
you'd to work wouldn't collide and in
other places know,
unless we all had the same hobby,
you know?
I mean how else do you like?
I know people from different worlds to
like the world of pool professional pool
and because pool players that I've known
for 20,
30 years,
like those people in that world.
I know those people,
but otherwise other worlds like you
gotta like do something they do,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I noticed really a lot like a lot of the
guys of your generation that,
uh,
they're very manly that when I,
when I,
when I first started,
there was a lot of like nebbishy guy who
talked about their mother and you know,
it's really changed is because come
much,
much more masculine like burr burrs.
Very manly.
Yeah.
But there was always guys like lenny
clarke,
he was real manly,
manly.
Well lenny clarke,
he could be like a bouncer and a
comedian.
Big man,
big savage.
um,
yeah,
there's uh,
you know,
I think this,
just like the doors open,
the fucking everybody now there's all
sorts of different shapes.
I always tell him,
I had a podcast yesterday and the kid
was muslim and I said,
you know,
when I started out there were no muslim
comedians.
I couldn't,
they wouldn't.
When I started at 1980,
there was nobody I could think of.
I mean,
remember when yaakov shamir was like a
crazy thing to see.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
From whatever country.
And you know,
what killed him,
perish striker,
let's say a purse.
Drake in Russia.
It was the same as here,
you know what he's been doing sets of
the store and he's fucking funny.
Good.
He's good man.
He's a good joke writer.
He writes good jokes.
He's a likable guy.
He's a nice guy.
And uh,
I've,
I've seen him many times now over the
past few months.
He's a real nice guy.
Yeah.
You know,
but he went to branson to read it,
to have a career there.
Well,
he has a theater there,
right?
They do at dinner shows and shit.
And he goes out and does standup.
They do like three in the afternoon
shows that didn't get to bed by six.
He still looks great too,
guys.
Fucking healthy.
It looks good.
They do 3:00 PM shows.
No kid.
You might be right.
I might be wrong.
It might be feeding him fucking boiled
carrots and shit.
Get gum.
All their meals.
That brand,
that places weird.
Has he been there?
No,
no,
I haven't been gone.
It's like an elephant graveyard.
Well,
it's a weird,
like real religious place,
right?
Well,
I didn't know that.
Isn't branson,
Missouri.
I polish it up.
Jamie,
it all super religious,
conservative,
you know,
kind of a midwest.
You don't really get too much
conservative without religion.
True.
It's real.
You don't get too much.
Like watch your language,
watch your behavior,
dress nice.
Don't say anything inappropriate.
Don't say anything controversial without
religion.
Like you really only get that,
that sort of strict behavioral standards
when they're applied to religion.
Like I was telling you about,
my friend who did the benefit,
his people are all religious.
I'll tell you who he is after this is
over.
I just don't want to blow the guy up.
He's a famous guy and his people are all
like really religious.
He's an athlete and so his idea of
what's acceptable and acceptable
involves what language you use,
like what words you use,
what subjects talk about.
That almost always comes with religion.
Yeah.
You know,
to be like real button down and super
judgmental.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just not allowing anything risque or
controversial.
Welcome to branson.
Let's have some fun.
Jim stafford show was just show me a
photo.
What does it say about the actual place
though?
I've never seen any pictures of it.
You couldn't find anything about branson
being religious.
Oh joe.
I'll tell you.
I love vegas.
I just do.
It's fun and,
and out.
Quit.
We got to do something.
I want to come and see.
You know,
your foot or something.
Let me know when you,
uh,
when you're doing gigs from there in
august with the laugh factory in june.
I told you with the brad garrett.
Okay.
what?
You have a fight in june?
No,
I don't know.
We'll figure it out.
What?
Good one.
And then we'll do like a gig together up
there.
Oh,
that'd be great.
Yeah.
should be fun.
Right?
Do a to get on the friday and then come
back.
Dominic.
Yeah.
There's some fun times to be had there.
Great restaurants too.
Oh man.
Best know what they did.
They went out and bought the best chefs
in the smart and you get to where the
airport.
You see these fucking big ass gordon
ramsay posters and all these other
chefs.
I know enrolled in the famous guys that
I've seen on the anthony bourdain show
and shit.
It's awesome and you can't get a bad
steak.
They're one of the major casinos there.
Stakes are off the charts.
What I used when I started there at a
six,
so at the comedy store,
it was all dollar 99 stakes,
ninety nine cent breakfast.
It was all like shit food for people
that would just gambled.
Then it's completely changed.
Steve wynn,
that had a lot to do with it.
I think he is.
He is a visionary.
Does a bunch of those guys that have
done a great job that the whole group,
like the cosmopolitan,
right?
Right.
Yeah.
And then the mgm has a fantastic steak
place.
A I,
I had the really expensive one just to
see how much better with a $260.
Colby beef where they might they massage
the,
the cow or the sphere.
The other.
Give it a fatty diet.
Give him a beer.
Crazy.
It's good.
Tastes good though.
What is it,
jamie?
I just got this place called the sight
and sound show.
They have all these religious shows
there.
Oh,
look at that.
I guess places bringing the bible to
life.
This is one of the big shows in branson,
bunch of shitty actors.
Whereas your mom was art show,
moses.
Oh,
I think I need to go to that.
I need to go to that on acid.
That be awesome to take a pot brownie to
get just like crippling,
scared high and then go to see this
would probably be amazing.
We need to film that for vice.
oh.
Oh my god.
Smith.
I just found something we can do.
Go to branson and we'll have a guy tried
to convert us.
I thought about going into one of those,
uh,
on hollywood boulevard.
Just letting them,
just seeing what they did.
The dynamics.
Yeah.
Just to make it all the time when I
walked down there,
just hey,
take care of to take a flyer.
I just want to walk in one time and just
see what they do.
They might get you bro.
You think they'd catch me if I had a
microphone on or something?
Uh,
yeah.
Probably.
Probably rescue.
And then they'll fuck you if they find
the mic.
So they do,
dude.
Um,
which that we might lose you to
scientology.
Then you might become a mole and you
come in here.
When we talk shit about tom cruise,
he sent a text to these people and then
they get mad and attack us.
Maybe it's already here.
They move tom cruise to some secret
hideaway.
Did you hear about this?
Yeah.
This is a recent thing.
He moved into l dot ron hubbard's
mansion in england.
He's like fixing it up.
L ron hubbard had an estate from which
he prepared for the tetons to come here
from far away galaxies to reclaim their
frozen souls that melted in the volcano
or whatever the fuck the story is.
Shitty ass writer.
Look at this.
pull up the title of this.
So a sprawling english estate fit for a
king of hollywood,
tom cruise set to pull up stakes and
move to st hill manor,
the former home of founder l dot ron
hubbard at Church of scientology uk
headquarters.
Who out of anybody who has kept it
together in the face of being a part of
a fucking whack a do cult like tom
cruise.
The fucking guy never answered a
question about it.
It doesn't.
He's talked about it briefly over the
years and every time it's been a
mistake,
but if he just keeps his fucking mouth
shut and acts,
he acts his little dick off and he looks
amazing.
He's a good actor.
He looks amazing.
He's in his fifties,
looks like he's 30 years old.
He looks amazing,
and he's a great actor.
That fucking,
what is it?
The tomorrow movie?
Edge of tomorrow that was always called.
That is a very good science fiction
movie and he's excellent in it.
He's fucking good,
man.
That's amazing.
If,
if he wasn't in a wacky cult,
if he was just like a regular guy,
would he be even bigger?
I mean,
was he bigger before?
What's bigger like.
Well,
I know he.
There was a drop off after that whole
glib thing.
Remember when he was accusing brooke
shields of being like,
of making a big mistake by taking psych,
psychotropic drugs for depression.
Remember that you had to make a comeback
and tropic thunder.
Yeah.
That was the comeback.
Well,
it was because he really fucked up.
He got on tv with matt lauer and he did
this really weird interview man where he
talked about like the importance of not
taking drugs to treat depression and it
was fucking range,
man.
It was really strange.
he's like,
matt,
you're being glib,
like lick.
But he was.
It was.
It was so awkward and goofY because you
realize like,
oh,
you don't even know how crazy you are.
Like you're constantly surrounded by
agents,
other actors,
managers and people you love and people
that love you.
So when you're sitting there tAlking to
a guy like matt lauer and you're
explaIning why brooke shields shouldn't
take medicine to treat her depression
because you believe that a frozen
phaeton was dropped into a volcano by a
fucking god of thunder from some
university was shaped like a thimble or
something.
I mean w w,
w what?
LAuer wanted to fight him when he called
hIm and he wanted to take tom cruise in
a wrestling match when actor called them
glip.
C'mon on gets arm wrestling.
Is it really?
I think I saw it mostly a wrestling
match is he wanted to wrestle it.
Told that to andy cohen.
He said,
hm,
okay,
stop these some gay stuff there.
Why do you want to wrestle a guy?
I just want to get on top you and
doMinated you.
Call me glib about you.
Choke on my dick.
The moment he thought,
can I take him in a wrestling match?
Could I tackle him on the set?
What do you imagine how dumb you have to
be?
The guy calls you glib and your reaction
is you want to attack him that you want.
I was thinking,
can I take him?
Can I take him male posturing?
Dom,
it's very dangerous.
I can't imagine doing that to matt
lauer.
I would love matt lauer just tackling
someone on show and just ground and
pound.
I would love to see that matt lauer just
passes.
God moves to full mount,
starts dropping elbows on people.
I don't think of him as a tough guy.
He's definitely not.
I worked with him a lot of times when he
used to be a guy in philly.
We hAve the news guy and billy,
it might be a tough guy,
but I mean I just don't think of him as
a guy who had assault someone for
calling them glib.
You didn't call them a dump.
Fuck.
Like,
listen,
you dump.
Fuck,
you don't know shit about medicine.
I'm a scientologist.
Okay,
dude,
I know.
Fuck these science psychologists,
scientists,
scientology's all you need.
Goddammit.
Brooke shields,
puerco,
tom cruise.
But it's amazing that he has stayed
relevant.
I mean there was that big drop off after
that,
but then his talent pulled them through
again.
He did a bunch of good movies.
Maybe it's because he does his own
stunts,
so he's just a crazy motherfucker and
people like them because of that.
He definitely does and he does
motorcycles.
Stents does some dangerous shift,
the playing thing,
all those mission impossible movies done
a lot of stuff.
He does a lot of stuff.
He's a bad motherfucker,
man.
He's crazy as shit,
but he's a bad motherfucker.
You can be both,
but he was.
He started in taps,
I think it was.
Do you remember that?
Yeah.
Well,
he's been in a bunch of movies,
man.
He was in That movie with ralph macho.
What was that fucking movie where
they're all like greasers and shit.
The law,
god dammit.
Outsiders,
the outsiders.
He was great in that.
He was always great.
It's fucking great actor is greater,
but I'm telling you that edge of
tomorrow movie is bad ass is one of the
best science fiction movies I've seen in
a long time and I think a lot of the
scifi geeks might have ignored it a
little bit because it's a tom cruise
movie because I think if it was just
like some really respected guy that
maybe people didn't know about,
maybe would,
uh,
would be appreciated more.
I really believe that.
I think that sometimes a guy like that
almost hurts a movie that's that good.
You know,
you expect him in like a blockbuster,
like a mission.
Impossible one of those action movies
totally makes sense.
But he's so god damn good in this movie.
I don't think people give them the
credit that he deserves.
It's a good movie if you're into those
kind of movies.
Like I love a good scifi movie and
that's a,
that's a great one.
It's one of the best scifi movies over
the last few decades.
When you say so jeremy?
Yeah.
They're getting ready to start to make
another one.
Supposedly it,
they're working on it right now
in this alien movie foot.
A bit of humor.
Oh,
kill us.
So when you go into city Australia and
what's the Oregon?
What's the sidney?
Uh,
I think I'm doing sydney opera house one
night.
he's doing the sydney and perth and I
know I have a gig,
a newcastle in the daytime.
Daytime bar gig,
which will be funny.
Oh,
that'S hilarious.
Yeah.
Do you have a show somewhere else that
night?
I don't know.
So you just couldn't do it in the day
know?
They have my schedule but I haven't seen
it yet.
So how many days are over there for
three weeks.
Three weeks.
Beautiful.
So we'll see when you get back to joe.
Thank you for me.
I,
joe,
I love you too brother.
All right folks,
that's it.
It for the week.
We'll be back next week with a ben
hoffman.
The dude who's now the a country music
singer in nashville.
Standard.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
He's going to be here on monday.
It's his act is hilarious with wheeler
walkers at his character's name.
I didn't even know about that.
you didn't know about that.
You're going to work.
We're going to find out.
It's fucking hilarious.
I'll tell you everything.
All right.
Good night everybody.
Bye.
See you soon.